[Music]
two
hello hello welcome welcome
it is monday march 28th
[Music]
how's everybody doing hope you had a
great weekend
i know we all did
we just got back from vegas yeah
so much to talk about today including
will
smith
uh wow so much to say about that
but first a quick thank you to
hellofresh look at all these delicious
meals from our fupa troopers
that's just a few of the delicious meals
we've tried through hello fresh with
over 50 minion market items to choose
from you can try something new every
week get 16 free meals plus three free
gifts with code
h3tv16 at hellofresh.com
h3tv16
well welcome everybody
all right i got a request
phone lines are open 808 hot meme if you
want to defend will smith because i know
there's a lot of people out there i
would like to talk to one of you
brain rotted freaks
stop calling
i don't know if we should talk about
vegas or this or the smith
let's talk about vegas let's let's not
let's not get
all heated right off the bat here
by the way
i'm going to be coughing a lot this
episode
okay excellent
uh so you know i was i was sick going to
vegas
and i was not easy on the body i was
drinking
i smoked a few which was not a good idea
but when in vegas you gotta do what the
vegans are the vegans the vegans the
vegans
it was a fun time though man it was a
blast fun time
otherworldly a good good time
and uh
lots of gambling lots of eating good
food we have quite the story about the
gambling actually what about the uh my
blackjack run
just the whole arctic weekend was
incredible
so the first you guys heard you we all
said you know
someone donated 100 bucks
to a b
to put on black yep and i said i put a
thousand and he also any requested we
all match that so
uh most of us i think did so i know i
threw in a 100 on that as the day oh you
guys did yeah oh wow so you no wonder
you cleaned up
that's where all that cheddar guacamole
came from
well anyway so i don't know how much we
had on there then like 1500 on black a
thousand of it was or 1100 if it was
mine 100 i gave to a b
and then there was one dude at the table
and so casually he just looks at me and
he goes
black 18.
now if you don't if you know anything
about roulette calling a specific number
is
very unlikely it's like what 1 in 64
something
odds are insane no not that 36 yeah 36
or 36 numbers on the wheel yeah well and
then if you include the two greens i i
guess it's 38 i guess it's one in 30
ounce yeah yeah
[Music]
so he goes a long shot though yeah so it
pays those odds like one two you know 36
or something
so he goes he's just like trust me dude
black 18.
i was like okay fine whatever dude i put
25 on black 18 which was the minimum bet
ball rolls
by the way i had such a crap time uh
experience leading up to this me and eli
went to get our flight
they wouldn't let elo on the plane
because her id was expired
not her fault by the way she's been
waiting for the dmv to renew her license
for like a [ __ ]
year
they will not send her a new id these
[ __ ] dude
you know i i didn't mention it but i've
been having the same issue
i mean
i mean i'm not the first person to
complain about the dmv but holy [ __ ]
yeah they suck
oh this mug is kind of an issue eh
oh yeah dude shout out to fiddlehead
fiddle had coffee
[Applause]
our boy our poopa trooper who called in
a few weeks ago
the coffee is fine the mug is nice shout
out to patrick i'm rocking his merch
today by the way oh my goodness
that is good coffee
nothing like a fine cup of coffee in the
morning
[Applause]
so anyway
a horrible time
so we missed our flight
and then we had to run to another
airport
get a flight with southwest
we were stuck in the airport for hours
whatever i was just i was like man this
sucks you know what i mean not a great
start to the weekend i was like it's
cursed already it's not your idea
right
but right but anyway we get to vegas i'm
like all right so i got like 1500 bucks
on black
25 on some random [ __ ] bet who cares
black 18.
and i was like oh come on baby we need
this now
we need this now more than ever it's
already so cursed
also add to the curse i got a speeding
ticket on the way in right oh yeah
93 you degenerate
[Laughter]
dude that's like the
there's always a speed trap on that
drive for me i know always
you know
in your defense zack i drive very fast
when i drive to vegas it's like it's an
empty [ __ ] straight road
it's so boring you just want to get
there i get it right and like the cop
was such a [ __ ] and it was bad i was
here dick you kept saying that well
you want me to explain yeah okay curious
so he pulled me over and i said oh hello
officer and he's like it's sergeant and
i'm like oh okay okay you're right that
is that it's like bro you're already
showing him
you're already showing him respect right
you know i was cool you know put my
hands on the wheel and he uh he's like i
need to see your driver's license and
i'm like okay it's in my pocket i'm
gonna reach for that you know just
throwing that out there make sure you're
very polite buy the book right
and then he's like how else are you
gonna get it oh cause he you were like
he was like i'm not gonna shoot you bro
you're white
right you're pretty much but you know i
i just i know yeah yeah you're right
he's a total douche keep going i love it
so then i we're stopped for maybe i
don't know two minutes
he comes out with this ticket that is
like this long
totally different than california like
goes down here
and you know he wrote me 93 and a 70. he
hands me the ticket doesn't say anything
and i i'm like i don't live here what do
i do he's like well figure it out it's
on the website
so wow and then
he gets in his car
and then he hauls out hall's ass out of
there because there was another person
speeding that he was going to chase
so
yeah i'd be upset too if i was a
glorified [ __ ] road nanny he was a
[ __ ] prick [ __ ] man yeah i thought
you were overreacting but the the the
sergeant thing is it's like you're being
respectful why do you yeah that guy is a
total dick yeah you know it's funny on
the way there
zach called me and asked where we were
at and i lied and i said i was an hour
behind and then when i got the phone
camera like oh why'd you say where i
were behind i was like because i feel
like if i tell zach we're that close
he's to speed and then shortly
afterwards
[Laughter]
it's so funny you're always playing 5d
chess baby
yeah so how far behind were you
it's an hour i think i said two hours
was only an hour no you said an hour
no i didn't say an hour yo and like i
found out ab speaking of you always
playing 5d chess you lied about smelling
amaranth's fart you said afterwards
you didn't smell the fart why you don't
gotta lie bro just oh no just be just
tell me it don't stink i don't need you
to lie
no we need
the show demands
the show demands
if we start faking reactions it caused
the whole show in the question i didn't
oversell it listen you said it didn't
stink but she's a friend of the show
it was it was just i don't know it's a
weird situation i have breathing
problems i thought maybe i was a little
[ __ ] up i didn't want to ruin these no
bro you did a snap well that's why i
didn't i was like let me smell the next
ones with zach and i thought zach would
oversell it but zach was honest so he's
always playing 5d chess and then i he
said i thought i smelled something and
he's like nah it's just my breath
[Laughter]
but i always think with good intentions
yes of course always with good intention
yeah and it's my little something i
maybe just
oversold a little bit that's not he told
us
anyway um
so we were in the middle of the uh
story sorry when we got off track so
anyway
we we placed the bed on the roulette
wheel
come on baby come on
it lands on black 18.
unbelievable it [ __ ] really did the
craziest thing we were there for like
[ __ ] 10 minutes right off the bat
just huge win so i obviously so my
thousand gets a thousand so i'm up a
thousand and then my 25 on the black 18
which is like such a
astronomical bet returns like 700 on 25
yeah
so i'm sit so i mean it was insane dude
the dude was so cool about it too he was
just like i gave him a hundred i was
like you're a wizard bro he like he was
so like nonchalant about it when we came
back by the way all of his money was
gone yeah that's how it was in vegas
that's how it goes yeah he lost it all
so
i was flabbergasted it was the best
start to a vegas trip ever yeah so i'm
sitting on three grand
and i give a hundred to everybody sure
did give 100 generous guys
the dealer
we have a great night of gambling
everyone was up but uh zacky boy who
took a big old
took a bit of a loss there on the night
right well i was up the first night we
got there and the next morning i was up
but it wasn't until we started all of us
hitting the tables that i would just
went down
so you lost you said 500 500 yeah and
does that include the money i gave you
um
yeah oh okay but you were very gracious
like when we were at the table he's like
hey here's a chip here's a chip keep
playing keep playing with us yeah you
were you were very cool and yes yeah
it's it's nice gambling with you yeah it
was definitely
keeping you guys keeping you guys whole
but we kept playing
i was losing my ass it was fun it was
fine
because i was enjoying just having fun
we were drunk just getting wild i'll put
like two i would lose 400 i will lose i
was like here's for the boys 800 down
it would you get a win ethan kept we
were playing blackjack mostly and he
kept going up and then he would get
excited and be like all in baby all in
not all in it would usually be like i
saw you lose on an all-in like three
times this week yeah because it was it
usually go i go like this i go
all right let's do a high energy round
200 and then i lose i say okay 400 let's
get it back and then i lose and i say
[ __ ] it
right and then i lose like 800. a lot of
them were pushes though like thank god
well here's the thing though because you
guys all make fun of me i was down 3 500
bro
i said all right [ __ ] it we're having
fun i don't care took another thousand
out
that's 4500 out it's a lot of money a
lot of money last night we're sitting at
the black table we must have played
there for eight hours that may have been
the most fun of my life yeah it was a
great time that was awesome yeah
drinking having a good time
so i sat with a thousand at the end of
the night my friends i left that table
with forty three hundred dollars and one
session you sure did and
you gotta
talk about the last hand what you went
out on oh my god
so we were all done we were all up
i was like i'm i'm good dude i had a
stack of like three thousand i was like
i'm not gonna touch this but i just
couldn't lose i kept saying
we had this one dealer she was like a
magician and i kept being like you can't
lose at this table
and i was like don't say it don't drink
it
don't jinx it i was like everybody
together you can't lose at this table
and
there was no jinx
she was great i couldn't lose
i told her you're a senator because
people kept taking pictures with you
yeah she believed you she did it first i
had a senator
she probably didn't that's
great
[Laughter]
she was yes ma'am i'm a senator for
nevada
i represent you
she was cool
she was amazing yeah
anyway so i've got like eight hundred
dollars left
and you know gotta keep it high energy
put it all in
hit a blackjack [ __ ] hit a blackjack
so i actually didn't really lose money
if you count all the money i gave you
guys at the start i'm up like a thousand
yeah
yeah
it was crazy
yeah we all did we all made up positive
except except me i thought i was gonna
go in and win a roar
that is crazy though because with the
way vegas works for for
i mean how many of us like eight of us
to be betting all weekend
all but one of us to come up that's it's
a pretty good weekend
unbelievable it was fun and blackjack i
don't know it was just so fun yeah great
time and love i mean you're you've never
been to any anywhere like that right no
you just turned 21 too eh yeah i've
never been in at the casino in person
but i've been gambling a lot online
right right
yeah you were you're a pro you're a
proficient uh gambler by the age of 15
yes yes yes so how did you like it
oh so great
blackjack
like the boys were sitting there for
like five six hours at one table
uh
then we moved we sat at another table
for five hours
yeah you gotta talk about the roulette i
think i said love has some crazy love
right yeah you did i believe you
mentioned it on the show um
well basically i went to roulette and i
hit the green over and over and over
again like five greens in a row in a row
yeah i stopped gambling in between and
then i went in i sat down
here put down put money in green and i
won so by the way green is like one in
you know 36 like the same as yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i count how many
uh greens how many
times it hasn't been green and i sat
down when it came around 18 rounds
without green and i hit it four times in
a row so then like the next day we all
wore green
or like this is gamba green right now
the first night after everyone else went
upstairs i didn't know how to play
anything prior i learned everything this
trip and i was asking everyone for help
but love was like my like phone a friend
yeah the first night we stayed and we i
mean love stayed there until we got
green and then we went to sleep i knew
love was still there there's gonna be
one more green
we bet a few more times got green and
then i went to bed yeah yeah i've been
to vegas a lot and i have never seen
like a group have as good of luck as we
had yet again it was blessed i mean the
last run on blackjack was insane yeah
i was gonna i just accepted i was gonna
leave with minus 4 500.
i was like it's fine that's fine right
got it all back and cameron i think had
more fun than anyone
okay i'm had a good time
cameron was like
he was he was walk he's just wandering
the city by himself
at times yeah we kept losing him and
then he founded don we found a
dominatrix that beat him up
we have footage of it but i don't know
if we could show it it's too graphic
well you've blur we blurred it you have
it ready yeah yeah you think it's good
to show i think i haven't screened it
but uh
i did a pretty good job of blowing
everything okay she's not naked the
thing is you can't show blurred nudity
but she's not naked she's not no no she
she's just scantily clad
all right let's roll it she was covered
yeah and do you have the win when i went
because we were filming the big win at
the top yeah i believe we have that yeah
okay it sounds horrible though the win
is in here first
okay so wait this one that says follow
up uh i don't i haven't seen this
because apparently you're not supposed
to film on the casino floor so it was
kind of ghetto
we promised you guys we would do it and
here's the results let's see
this was our first moment in the in the
casino
there it is guys each one of those is a
hundred dollars
and then there
everyone's in
and then there's my 25
on black 18. eight you keep saying 18.
homie was with me too there's the guy
the legend
i kept being like baby needs the diapers
baby needs formula
i'm trying to make everyone think i'm a
degenerate gambler
i didn't even realize it hit eight and
look at that guy dude's just like yup
he told you yeah i told you bro no big
deal
unbelievable it was such an incredible
moment
all right let's get to cam getting his
ass beat by dominatrix
and cameron the thing is we were all
like
he wants to get beat by this dominatrix
and then everyone was like super uncomfy
with the id and cam was like
it was like obvious that cam wanted in
on the action he was doing the
[ __ ]
i was like bro you need to get your ass
beat if you're doing that
yeah every time we did it i told her to
hit him harder because he kept doing it
as he was being whipped doing that but
now they're that now they're friends
instagram friends and i think there
might be something i heard they're going
to dinner next weekend
yeah
is she your type cameron
uh this was a first for me and it was it
was a lot of fun i won't lie
it was a very thrilling experience yeah
i was open to it and uh it paid off yeah
you date all right
i'm sorry i is she your type and
um
we just met let's take it slow yeah
let's take it she just spanked my ass
we'll take it slow
sounds like a first date to me
but she seemed to take a liking to you
too cameron she was very pretty
would you would you let her stomp on
your genitals oh my god because i don't
know how far she wants to take it in the
bedroom are you down with all that kind
of domination i don't think i'm at that
point yet but you know uh she was very
she was very kind and she broke
character to make sure i was doing okay
that was very sweet yeah well she kept
whipping him and i i was close because
amy was filming and i was watching him
um i saw her pull him aside and whisper
like you're okay right we're friends
you're having fun yeah i thought i was
like that's really nice then i gave her
another 10. i'm like come on
step it up
enough with the nice guy [ __ ] i mean
i'll say at first i could take it and
then you can see on my face when it
becomes genuine pain
so yeah i mean i guess that remains to
be seen but yeah all right here we go
oh i was trying to full screen it there
we go weird and bro
by the way youtube bullshitters watching
she is not naked she is she's on the
street obviously she's not naked so
we're just censoring it to keep it pg
with peace and love
[Music]
guys can you record some blackmail
against your friend here raise your
hands right here nice and nice i look at
her and you say i'm in trouble i'm in
trouble
such a good sport cam i'll say that such
a good
oh sport this is too much for me
um it looks like the 22 i saw is turning
into a glock 9.
you didn't pop one did you i was too
scared to look no she was saying that to
everybody yeah yeah that's just the bit
but that's the bit i was like oh god
please cameron don't be a
look at this
okay yeah i didn't think so just wanted
to clarify that only locked and loaded
now sir can i ask you something have you
been assaulting anyone with this weapon
no no you should have saw me with the
weapon no no oh good answer turn it
around
okay get sexy
there we go now look at me
say mistress
by the way this one has the best racket
man like when we were done another
people came
she's getting 20s non-stop oh yeah what
what again hooked up what a good
creative job she's out there
the only good cop in vegas
gotta make sure you learned your lesson
yes sir i can learn my lessons
[Applause]
that was that when it started to hurt
that looked pretty hard
that last round but i was really feeling
it here
no can i release him back to you no
no he's like keep them
trying to get in trouble
how about for ten bucks
well it's a little bit more available
i mean
[Music]
so you know what you do got to build
yourself out of jail while you're here
you already know that all right there we
go you ready to have some fun sure
we're friends right now
for you yes sir yes
yes ma'am
[Music]
yeah it's fun
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh you're the man cam
yeah you're a good sport
lina was laughing too hard so she had to
pass off the camera the phone baby
thank you very much
but we had great dinners i gotta say the
food was bomb dude that first place we
went to i was like we waited two hours i
was ready to bail
the food we were good boy fancy we saw
chris angel there we saw we saw the mine
we saw him in the restaurant it's funny
when you go to hotel
chris angel the mind freak
all over this town especially our hotel
because that's where his show is
was like mine freak and he's they're all
jacked with the six pack looking like
he's
30 years old
i was like [ __ ] my freak
man you must have might freak me because
you don't look anything like those
posters
like he does not look like he does in
those posters boy no
then at all we saw him like when he got
up
ethan you're like mommy we need to get
him we need to get him like what's up
chris
i didn't do that
you know that exactly yeah you're like
hi chris he's like hey buddy i'm saying
i said chris i said hi to him that was
dope that's what i'm saying
[ __ ] yeah zack said hi to mine freak
i haven't been the same since dude
you've been mind freaked i've been mind
freaked
mine flipped
yeah i'm starting a new show uh next uh
next door called mine flipped and it's
gonna be posters of me with six packs
all over the city
we gotta show the
we gotta show the photo we took outside
the restaurant right here the curse
phase oh yeah so then
i don't know what happened we took one
group photo
it's so cursed bro
i think the hostess took it she did not
do a good job with peace and love to her
it's like so confusing like this one is
like extra first
that this is i i don't think you ever
saw what we were seeing because when you
sent it through the messaging app it
like compressed the [ __ ] out of it and
like turned it it like stole our souls
and turned us all like 40 years older
the way i i need to be able to zoom more
i need to i need to get any further
wait maybe maybe control plus it's all
over the subreddit
uh cropped in photos
no i it's all the way in
you see this before you call me a
loser
all right so let's take a look at the
faces he looks fine she looks good
i mean
the thing is and i won't let me go to
the left can anybody explain why my life
is is hell
just kidding it's not that bad
but like okay
why did it zoom all the way over there
and it won't let me go to the right
you know
all right let's take a look he looks
good i look like
fat mask i don't know
love is just his face was burned in a
yeah what the hell you have like a face
transplant
yes
maybe
unibrow
yeah it does look like i don't know bro
it's all
arena looks good zach you look kind of
good too
and low res other than my like
protruding red face and like
smile lines
i mean chantelle looks good in low-res
dan looks [ __ ] bro [ __ ] this that's
the joker face it looks like you're in
front of one of those high velocity fan
like jets to blow them right yeah yeah
cameron doctor strange love
all the ladies look good in low res i
wouldn't say anything about them
and and then it distorted you ian to
make you look like you're seven feet
tall and like super wide it made me look
tiny
and ian looks like a giant like what did
she do she took the photo like this
it looks like my head my head's sort of
like heading off to greenland or
something
how is it to be seven five bro
feels good yeah ian's fit was like
[ __ ] fly as [ __ ] by night also okay
everyone's making fun of me because it
says gonna dress nice
i brought all my nice clothes and i am
here to tell you now that i'm too fat to
fit in them and [ __ ] my life
and uh something must be done wally
that's not nice something must be done
but i did bring all my nice clothes and
it didn't fit so i said i what can i do
i'm just gonna be comfortable none
yeah
so there you have it it was a great time
though
such a fun time man
um
there there you go anything else you
guys want to talk about no just
appreciate you guys thank you
uh ethan neela funded the whole trip and
uh
ethan was a sugar daddy the whole time
[Music]
yeah we thank you very much i mean what
the [ __ ] did you do what is this cam use
there's some service online that uses an
ai to try and upscale or like operate
photos
wait can we do that on everybody's i
come up during the show and get an album
of everybody's face getting did you do
it on anybody else
okay maybe maybe for next time people
are asking if there will be a behind the
scenes
guys it was really tough to get footage
in there i apologize
i'll put a few clips that we got we were
in the casino for like 90 of the time
and you're not allowed to film in there
look i just i wanted everyone to have
fun i don't want anyone to be having to
worry about work
but it was fun you know i'm glad you
guys deserve a break you guys it was it
was just a great time you guys deserve
it all and i'm glad everyone had fun i
sure did and then this weekend we're
going to disney
and i don't [ __ ] care who knows
oh right oh yeah
yeah cares why do you guys care so much
we're not
i guess we don't care we do the vip
thing if it gets but i'm happy to say hi
to the fans okay
you know
so it's a non-stop thrill ride
i guess we're making up for last year i
mean we didn't do anything fun last year
right and we're given love of the
california and southern california
experience you know yeah
i don't know if the fans knew yet but
i'm leaving next monday
very very sad
next monday yeah
so this weekend we go to disney and he's
out and then monday you're leaving
mm-hmm holy [ __ ] bro at least
before you leave that's sad
it's gonna feel
can i say about anything we're doing in
behind the scenes or no regarding
maybe not no
let's just say
that if there's a
oh
[Music]
right we're back did we both go for that
ian
both of us hit at the same time so it
kind of [ __ ] up
i just want the fans to know
that
basically if something
is
blah blah blah
stop
all right well keep it read between the
lines okay thank you very sad very
depressing
i've had so much fun out here uh thanks
to all of you guys in the office here so
i want to thank you guys
and the fans of course for making this
all possible at the start
love you all
bye love you love you
when you get home so much good energy to
the office
well look when you get back we can do a
bachelor season
because if you get engaged while
overseas
then we can do a 90-day
that's right i mean tlc could do it why
can't we
i just i have to say i've incorporated
loves like vernacular into my own sure
have like juicer and like when i don't
like someone i'm like hey love what do
you call those people [ __ ] [ __ ] bro
we're all been saying [ __ ] and
juicing yeah more than we should yeah
yeah
also before we move on
too far past the vegas thing uh the dude
who donated the hundred bucks that we
put on roulette
he donated another hundred bucks and he
said i'll do it again uh [ __ ] uh
wait wait we gotta go and now i gotta go
pay for another vegas trip because this
guy just donated a hundred bucks you
gotta go again
thanks to your donation it helped really
set the tone of the vacation because we
all i wouldn't have put that thousand i
don't think if that guy didn't donate
yeah so appreciate you man yeah that was
a huge one from the from the super
trooper who donated yeah
man it was fun time probably the most
fun i've had in vegas
usually when i go to vegas it's just it
just turns into a nightmare and i wish i
was home sooner
that's great
i should go back again i could play i
could play blackjack and drink all day
with y'all
[ __ ] out dude
i gotta win that 500 back yeah well oh
yeah i almost died of red bull overdose
too oh yeah
i was like we're like love how many
ripples you have today he's like six
he's sitting there
we're like what the [ __ ] bro you can't
do that the dealer had to take the
string away
yeah she told him she's gonna get water
she's like you need water dude yeah i've
been sipping on like red bull vodkas all
day
non-stop and i when i was i would all of
a sudden notice that i couldn't hold the
ships i was dropping them in between my
in between rounds and [ __ ] it's horrible
red bull is barely safe to be consumed
it made love look like a red bull by the
end of the night his whole face and oh
yeah
i got all the words
he looked like he got stung by a bee and
when we brought it up he was like so
what [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's like welter for [ __ ] [ __ ] man
yeah yeah i went with him to the
bathroom so he could go take a look and
check on himself he takes two seconds
like what the [ __ ] is everyone talking
about just walked out
did he do the
not even time to make the sexy face
i think [ __ ] these
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
well anyway everyone's okay
yada yada
all right let's talk about will smith
yeah but you don't want to you want to
see this
little clip we included right here which
one
about the alabama governor oh yeah let's
yeah let's we have two more shorts very
short and i think you'll enjoy it and
then we'll talk about will smith willard
smith covid team
so yes we're in touch
governor can you talk about the
numbers that you talked about yesterday
in washington
do you want
now
the increase in taxes
they are um
we're getting
excuse me a slight increase in the
number of doses that we'll be getting to
the state
so that's good news it's not as much
that's it
jesus it's like what's so intense she
needs some medical attention
that didn't sound good at all
cobin what are you talking colvin you
are you are walking coffee right now
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's a wild sound man you should be on
a ventilator not out doing a press
conference
that's it yeah play again
it's like an animal i don't know
sounds like a pig a pig eating
a pig
oh my goodness uh it's a little bit of
an older clip but somehow we missed it
and since we've
james i don't even know if i could post
this girl's picture
to be honest
it's just i mean it's a man i don't see
why not why not it's a shirtless man
james charles you really need to just
leave the internet okay because he
posted this
that is so true
he posted this which is basically a
crime against humanity
okay now you know
my goodness man
this is just over over the line
when you're james charles you don't get
to post the [ __ ] like this anymore well
so
it's it's shopped right like he doesn't
he
well can anyone yeah it's gotta be it's
gotta be but how big are you just he
just quote tweeted it and said oh my god
uh
well the problem is like don't
don't
signal boot don't amplify that no
you get a picture those aren't as nips
those aren't snaps are they small but
how big are they you know i think
they're normal nips they're normal not
pepperoni size yeah
pepperoni doesn't matter
i've pepperoni again after looking at
that photo i think it's time that we
talk hello pepperoni obviously i'm sorry
but
hell no bro
hell no
this is a little spooked
every time a teenage a young teenager
enters a chat room or something they
should get a pic be like warning this is
who you could be talking to
just a psa you know
or maybe for parents like your parent
your children could be talking to this
individual is that something you're
comfortable with
there ian just post it here i got you
i'll pull it up right now the original
okay let's check out his his nips there
yeah they're they're normal yeah
standard issue
yeah nothing to write home about there
but yeah james stop just stop
why don't you take a seat right over
there yeah
those nips are just you can't retweet
[ __ ] like that bro
um
you know the good news is though about
james charles i will say
i mean while
he does still have an audience which is
disturbing but
his views have
continued to drop off big time i mean
his video from three days ago has eight
hundred thousand views
yeah which is a lot but yeah i mean he
was pulling crazy numbers before the
scandal so dude that is a huge drop-off
yeah
if you go back a year
his video i don't even think that's
enough to fund to fund his cr his lavish
lifestyle anymore like he's gonna have
to drop his
his
his quality of life there a little bit
off these numbers don't you think
i'm sure he'll he'll be fine i know
right i mean but but yeah i mean yeah
obviously he was probably making
probably way more money before he's
going to make it like 20 million a year
probably to like
one million which again a lot of money
well knowing why
when you live in a 10 million dollar
house and your mortgage is 100 000 a
month yeah i'm looking at a social blade
it looks like it was around 150 million
views a month that's that's now yeah
that's 20. yeah that's like but also the
sponsors that's what i was going to say
yes the sponsor money is the real loss
there i mean 150 million
a month is huge huge ad rev but yeah man
but he he probably made so much money he
doesn't have to think about it ever
again so whatever
but okay it's i'm glad that people are
at least tuning out there
all right talking about
uh
degenerate freaks let's move now to will
smith
who i am not going to mince words about
there today to be a lot of people online
who straight up think
that
attacking first of all there's like a
few layers of how bad this is
i'm sure everyone by now knows what
happened i was going to say probably but
maybe just in case
some people in the audience don't know
what we're talking about so the clip
chris rock why am i trending oh god here
we go
don't look at that right now
you're going to get sucked i should say
b and me
okay they're just blown sometimes they
do that i'm trending
maybe he's trying to it just says no
it's your tweet when i clicked my name
so what's happening right now ethan
klein trending with ela because those
aren't those are those are like the fake
out trends i know i know but but
sometimes
yeah sometimes it's real but that is one
day i go boy cause there's a lot of
people very angry at me
for apparently advocating against
violence
right
so okay
chris rock
is emceeing the show
he now you guys know
he's hired to do this job
good chance that all of his jokes before
were written by other people and vetted
already
it's live television they don't take any
chances with this stuff
and there's a good chance he'd even
write the [ __ ] joke which wasn't a
good or funny joke a high probability
yeah
so
and by the way
when you come to the oscars and you sit
in the front row
you know you're gonna get ribbed okay
will smith
is one of the richest most famous dudes
in the world people [ __ ]
think he's a god fortnite he's got the
best job in the world all you got to do
is [ __ ] act and he gets paid hundreds
of millions of dollars and people suck
his dick wherever he goes like
proverbially
and maybe physically i don't know what
he gets into
but you know what i'm saying like
okay
so
the one night you sit there and the god
on his high throne has to come down
to to the
to the people's level and endure some
light ribbing from legendary comedian
chris rock
he can't deal with it
chris rock says something totally
innocent like
you know jada is sitting there next to
him
and
she is
bald she has no hair she has hair though
she i saw pictures she has stubborn
shave yeah i didn't even see patches in
her stubble i don't know
maybe it's in the back or something
apparently she has alopecia
is that right yeah which is a condition
where you lose hair
i've looked it up online i don't know
much about it but i saw people with like
batches of hair it's an autoimmune it's
your your immune system for some reason
forgets that your own hair is uh part of
your body and starts attacking it so is
it cause any is it more serious than
just like some hair so from what i under
the condition itself no um however
because it's an autoimmune thing it
oftentimes can be seen as an early sign
of other sort of autoimmune problems
that can crop up but in of itself the
only you lose hair you lose hair that's
on your head or your whole body well
there's different degrees of it some
people lose hair all over the place some
people it's just patchiness it just
totally depends it's yeah well it seemed
to me you could pull up a picture of her
on the red carpet before i didn't even
see patches in her shaved head
if it's makeup makeup or something it's
very possible yeah but anyway
i didn't know she had alopecia i think
it's very possible that chris rock
didn't
know she has alopecia who the [ __ ]
follows your life or cares
so chris rock says oh i can't wait for
gi joe gi jane two
so wow so [ __ ] offensive
it's like the tamest joke you can make
it's such a like dated joke too
it's not a good joke by the way yeah it
wasn't funny in fact i didn't even think
it was meant to be funny he's just
trying to acknowledge that she's there
it was literally filler yeah
okay
and by the way gi jane was a big deal
when it came out with demi moore in her
prime beautiful woman basically he
called her beautiful
i keep seeing people say that i don't
really buy that it's definitely okay
well it's a ball he was he was making it
but it's not a bad comparison
like sure she she says uh you could be
j.i jane because you have no hair right
now cool
i mean
one of the characteristics from that
movie is that it was played by demi
moore who's beautiful
that's what people remember for whatever
who gives a [ __ ] yeah the point is it's
a tame joke okay it's not funny
extremely tame
it wasn't funny you're right alex jones
now what's weird about it is that will
smith is laughing at first
and then you show jada and she's all
[ __ ] sour
she don't like that you made fun of her
being a baldy
she don't like it
how dare you
say i'm gonna be in g.i jane
so anyway lil will smith loving it
having a good time jada sour
then all of a sudden
chris rock is moving on wasn't a big
deal
will smith goes up on stage
open hand slaps him in the mouth
pretty hard
seemingly though hard enough yeah
abe said he he
showed a proper boxer stance yeah i
still remember what he learned from
making that ali movie because he was in
a good he's protecting yeah dude he was
like he got like center of gravity he
like he like planted his
legs on the ground
wound up that was like a proper slap
i don't know he thinks he's a pimp or
something
slap another man
also
chris rock is not tall
he's a small
a smaller gentleman i don't know how
tall he is
will smith i met him at the youtube
shows he's a massive he's a giant
do you think if like
the mountain was presenting that will
smith would have gone up and slapped him
he's five ten uh chris five ten and and
will smith is like six four or something
he's huge six two
is he a zack six two or like
a an actual 16
it's just getting sick do you think he
would have snowed
you think it would slap the mountain
uh i think he might have been a little
more hesitant i don't think he would
have slapped the mountain yeah i don't
i really don't
so he walks away
sits down all angry
i don't think we need to show it because
we're just gonna claim the whole [ __ ]
episode
but you guys have seen it you can watch
it if you haven't oh yeah the academy we
can show frames and stuff if you guys
want
you could play the audio or you could
i could play it out here
if it's if we need to
but it goes back sits down
the audio cuts out because they start
cursing but there's other sources where
you can hear it thank god
so chris rock goes wow dude you just
slapped me over a g.i jane joke and then
will smith screams
keep my wife's name out your [ __ ]
mouth
he's like dude chill what's wrong with
you whatever
paraphrasing
he goes i said keep my wife's name out
your [ __ ] mouth
and then chris rock i think
acknowledged i think
he had took a mental note of
how insanely unstable he was and just
wanting to defuse the situation said you
know
i'm your god i will yeah he's like i
will what i of course wish he said was
you know
well
if jada smith could keep
if will if if what's her name
if jada could keep her son's friend's
dicks out of her mouth oh my god then
just you know
this maybe you should explain that in
case people aren't aware yeah jada's
[ __ ] the entanglement as yeah she
she's
she's weakly humiliating will smith on
her facebook show she was she literally
ruined it he she has ruined this man
like the [ __ ] that she's exposed on him
just for clout on her dumb ass facebook
show
it's just been endless humiliation to
him
she had sex with um
august uh jayden smith
friends
yeah who are like young teenagers or 20
year olds not teenagers
you know at the time of their affair he
was 22 she was like 43 or 44 or
something like that so yeah it's a
little it's a little weird no it's
disgusting like people kind of brush
past that pretty quick but
well when it's the opposite everyone's
quick to say how gross it is i'm sorry
but your mom [ __ ] your friends is
disgusting
yeah keep the [ __ ] in my mouth here's
the photo and let's say they have an
open relationship but i don't know i
feel like i feel like uh your your
children's friends should probably be
off limits in that kind of situations
well and how about dating how about
whatever and you know
um
yeah the joke going around online was
they have their the only thing they're
not open to is light jokes about them
they're all their relationship is open
to everything but jokes right
a lot of people were quick to say it was
fake
definitely is real just stop
i don't want to even hear actually i'll
talk to someone who thinks it was fake
but i think
i think most people have moved on beyond
the the fake thing uh
especially if you see the clip because i
would say
when i initially saw it
as i was watching it i was like okay
this this could have been like a planned
thing yeah as soon as you see
will back in his seat screaming
that's not fake like right that was the
part where i was like oh that is 100
percent real rock stumbled he really
you know they they all cut the audio
yeah
it was definitely real
i mean will smith is just he's deranged
i mean the man
the man needs therapy more than he needs
he obviously has way more thetans to
remove
that the scientology they have a lot of
work to do on him
there's long-standing rumors that
they're scientologists well they donated
to scientology and they
and they had like a school
that no they had a school that was
people are saying this sounds so
anti-black shut the [ __ ] up what are you
talking about you dumbass [ __ ] you
what's anti-black about what i'm saying
you [ __ ] freak
how dare you idiot
that's disgusting
i mean just [ __ ] you
what am i saying that's anti-black you
want to make this about race so bad it's
two black men having an argument i have
not said anything about race it's about
going up
and [ __ ] committing violence in
response to a light joke
shut the [ __ ] up
seriously
god
what the [ __ ] could stop watching my
show you [ __ ]
he's just pathetically [ __ ] like you
don't have to see first i'm someone
that's very conscious about race issues
and stuff
you don't have to see everything through
the prism of race this is two men
this is [ __ ] about toxic masculinity
this is about
someone who resorts to violence when
they're angry
if you need to make this about race
you're a [ __ ] loser okay
[ __ ] you
stupid ass
synthetic somebody call a racist so much
on twitter for this i was like i'm sorry
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
i i'm allowed to have an opinion about
this
this is pathetic dude
what are you talking about
anyway
get off that for a minute
holy [ __ ]
um
there's
so anyway here hold on i got a note for
someone
yeah i mean exactly
people come to my house and threaten me
over jokes
people people i've talked to comedians
when they go on stage they're getting
heckled
and people now think it's okay to go
attack them while they're on stage
now people go
i see a lot of people going he talked
about his wife man
she has alopecia [ __ ]
alopecia
okay no it's insensitive i get it she's
not [ __ ] dying dude she's not dying
of cancer if she was sitting there on
oxygen right and she had like a month to
live fighting leukemia or some [ __ ] and
well and then chris rock's like what's
up [ __ ] keeper
i guess you'll be uh
you'll the [ __ ] keeper obviously
from the crypt keeper to the [ __ ]
like
i'm sorry like i get that some jokes
could push things too far this was not
one of them even remotely close i don't
[ __ ] care that she has alopecia
just saying it's not a death i'm sure
having alopecia could be stressful
and difficult losing your hair
somebody who's lost their hair uh can
you know
something you'd be very self-conscious
about absolutely but it is not deadly
it's not the [ __ ] it's not the line
in the sand okay let's just be real am i
supposed to go fight someone every time
they make fun of my tourette's is that
really the world we want to be living
people have been quote tweeting me
shipping like you don't know anything
about defending your wife
i don't know what the [ __ ] that they're
talking about yeah
i was defending you all the time oh they
say no no you got to go track down
trisha you need to go track down
keemstar and anyone else that dare speak
about my woman
who by the way
stay at home in the kitchen i'm going to
track down these enemies
be safe and wait for me stay in the
kitchen it's it's
chauvinistic very i mean it's very
misogynistic to be like
i must defend my woman
she is a fragile little flower
and i must attack anyone i'm sorry but
what kind of girl
this is just toxic freak [ __ ] all around
what sane woman
wants their man to go attack somebody in
public on a world stage that's
humiliating and it's embarrassing y'all
if he would have been a class act
excuse me
the class act would have been
a way more effective he wins the award
he goes up and says yo chris that joke
about my wife wasn't wasn't it but
then everyone would have you know
yeah if he had won the award which
yeah i guess again if anybody is somehow
unaware of the situation about five
minutes after all this went down he won
the oscar for best actor i'm getting to
that yeah um but yeah if he uh
if he went up there and you know dressed
chris down i mean
everybody's respect for him would have
gone through the route right
like i got to speak up for my wife you
know yeah
absolutely expressed you know you don't
know what she's gone through behind
closed doors as a woman it's not easy to
lose your hair you know and it's been
tough for her i've had to sit and see
her cry and deal with all this stuff if
you explain himself then yeah that'd be
nice chris probably would have
apologized
now again
even then it's like
uh you know i still think it was a tame
joke for anyone to get offended about
especially mega rich [ __ ] celebrities
who are at the oscars
in the front row
when you know the tradition at those
things is to be made fun of
someone said bad take ethan you
insulting everyone who disagrees is
closed mind and childish i don't listen
if you disagree colin if you think i'm
being racist you can [ __ ] die
that's that's the i mean some count some
counter arguments are not valid right
like if you disagree with me for some
reason
you can i'm i'm i'll open my ears and
listen okay even though i think it's
insane
to somehow think this was justified
but if you think i'm being racist then
you should just [ __ ] uh
death to all of them
if you think i'm being racist then just
[ __ ] delete uh system 32 or whatever
that was a deep cut thank you yeah
i i'm not going to entertain that i mean
you could call in because i think it'll
be entertaining you know but like you're
it's just mind rot if you think i'm
being racist
your brain is so [ __ ] rotted out
right now
that uh i'm surprised you were able even
to turn on your computer this morning
you [ __ ] idiot
do you even feed yourself
you probably see racism and everything
dude how do you even live your life shut
up [ __ ] ass
damn
going xqc up in here
so okay
anyway
um
so uh
yeah so the weird is what's really weird
is that
chris rock i mean will smith
assault someone on live tv and let's not
forget
even if you think the joke was offensive
chris rock is a legend the man deserves
respect
like nobody's talking about chris rock
deserves a little [ __ ] more respect
than that bro you don't just go slap a
man because he offended you especially
chris rock okay
the man deserves some [ __ ] respect
and by the way the academy shame on you
disgusting
[ __ ] pathetic loser institution is
dead
by the way
i will never watch this show again
chris rock
went up there
to do his job that he was hired to do
and they can't protect him for being
assaulted
no security shame no reaction
i'm sorry
you hired
chris rock to do a job
you have an obligation
for that man to be safe there
now who the [ __ ] else are going to rush
the stage during a live show and attack
chris rock
and then sit down and have a good time
and smile and clap
[ __ ] that man's a criminal
committed act of violence
i'm sorry
ah
well [ __ ] you will smith you petty
little [ __ ]
fragile is what you are
you and your
you don't wife me man
because you're a [ __ ]
freak dude you need help that's why
i'll tell you what if uncle phil was
alive right now man
he's rolling in his grave bro
it's sad yeah i love will smith it's
it's
every celebrity i like i just whatever i
should warn
all my favorite celebrities they're all
going to be
i will smith he's he's really held
himself well through his career yeah and
all of a sudden the man just
he really ex like dude
kelly and that's one of the reasons i
think so many people are defending him
because he's just been clean for so long
they feel like
it's just an instinct but they're
definitely in the wrong okay we have a
lot of people who want to debate me so
just hang on i want to finish my point
and then i'll take some i think
yeah yeah
everyone everyone on hold just hang on
i'll get to you okay
thank you guys
excuse me guys i'm sorry for all the
coughing
i took some medicine but
i don't know how well that [ __ ] works
so anyway
will smith sits there
laughing enjoying the show
you know
the academy the producers the venue they
do nothing
they condone violence
clearly
and then
will smith wins
an award for what was it best actor yeah
this actor
for king richard great movie close up
standing ovation from the crowd these
people are
you know i know everyone says that
hollywood is like full of these [ __ ]
brain rotted freaks
and you really see it i mean it's a room
full of people giving a standing ovation
to a man who just punched someone in the
face for making a joke he didn't like
what
world are we living in
what the [ __ ] is going on
how is this real life
how is this
real i mean
i don't know
the world is not flabbergasted
no no no true carlos
you know um
let's see
chris rock apparently made jokes about
them in
2016. how long ago was that now four
five six eight years
six six years ago
okay
god forbid will smith gets made fun of
one of the richest most successful
actors in the world have some humility
you [ __ ] fragile [ __ ]
i mean really
people saying the number isn't working
the the lines are full there's a billion
people trying to call in i'm sorry guys
maybe i'll take a call so we can um
we can um
refresh the lines
do you have any recommendation because
basically have like six callers and
they're all just want to debate me do
you have it which one of these people
sounds like the juiciest
uh
let me
check with
the screener let's see i'll just take
one um i'll take the oldest one
chandler
madison you want should i talk to a
woman sure or a man here let's talk to
madison i don't know it could be either
gender madison okay tell me why i'm
wrong hello okay hi madison
go ahead hi
thanks for calling
um a long time listener first time
caller obviously love you guys love the
show love you um
a lot of points also first and foremost
go banana slugs but anyway
so
basically
i want to talk about
raise i don't want you to get too heated
ethan but i'm going to give you a
discourse into why the black community
is overwhelmingly in support of will in
this situation if that's
[ __ ]
just try to okay go ahead i'm listening
okay go ahead i'm listening go ahead so
you got the floor okay
so online the discourse has like
obviously taken two camps and
what i've seen objectively on my
timeline is the people who are anti-will
there's an overwhelming amount of white
people on that side and there's an
overwhelming amount of black people on
the side that are for will so i think so
what is your what is your what what is
your what is your anecdotal evidence for
that yeah
well i just said my timeline okay so
you're saying so i mean obviously i
haven't done the data but i'm saying on
my timeline what i've seen so this is
based on your output okay so you we have
no empirical data to support this but go
ahead no empirical data but this is my
what i've seen so obviously again
that's why i said that so this whole so
is this whole premise based on your
assumption that black people are
supporting
well
because i don't know if we're
willing to take that stance here
okay that's fine
um i just wanted to say that what i've
seen is in the discourse what a lot of
white people are talking about is the
moment itself
and i'm not here to say that it was
good bad
a good or bad choice it wasn't you're
not why not wait you're not willing to
say that attacking someone for making a
joke is a good or bad choice
i'm saying it was a choice that it was
that was made no no no no no you gotta
tell me what was she watching i will not
accept your next premise unless you tell
me if will smith attacking chris rock
was a good or bad choice did he deserve
it
yeah
you have to talk did he deserve it yeah
you will not answer that i can't
okay
what i will say is it was definitely
inappropriate to slap someone on
national tv live
what about not live on national
television should you slap out at a bar
yeah
people get slapped every day i don't
know so so you think will smith
so you think will smith slapping a well
okay it does matter he was hired to tell
jokes right so this is a comedian right
i understand that i understand it wasn't
some random dude that came up the will
was like what's up baldy to his wife in
front of him right okay no i understand
context is important and i know you were
saying that obviously
okay so
so was will smith
right or wrong in what he did
what do you write
go ahead
what's in your heart okay
objectively know
my emotions out of it no is it something
i would do no is that fair
can i continue so you say you say will
was wrong
i'm saying objectively yes
okay what about subjectively no was it
fair no
a lot of things are wrong in this
situation i'm not sitting here trying to
say that slapping someone at an event
that's clearly a work event for all of
these people
is a thousand percent acceptable and
honorable i'm not one of those people
that's like he was like
okay so obviously what you were saying
i mean racially speaking in the
discourse on the black side of the
conversation
is that
chris rock
presents as a certain type of black
person and that's because of the 2016
oscars and him basically crossing the
picket lines and being a scab
again that's a lot of people's takes
that's not necessarily my take about him
choosing to hosa oscars in 2016.
but my take about that is what he said
about the protest in general which was
the oscars so white protest which i
think we can all agree
the industry is not very diverse wait
wow sorry i'm lost what are we talking
about we're talking about
chris rocks did what about
chris rock in 2016 hosted the oscars and
that's where all those clips are online
yeah right so he said
right so what are we talking about
strikes
so
he crossed the picket line in a
metaphorical sense because jada and will
were the ones who started the protest
oscar so white you remember that right
not really i don't follow oscar drama
but they were they were protesting the
oscars
because of some race stuff because
based on race yeah they're protesting
okay because they wanted more
republicans oh i see so so chris rock
was like i i'm not i'm crossing the
picket on your protest
got it no well i mean obviously he
didn't say that no i get it i get what
you're saying i i unders i follow that's
what people felt that's what people felt
you know what i mean it's like dude you
know this industry is why to tell like
let's be real they're not fighting for
anything but on top of that he got on
stage and basically making jokes about
her career and also the the protest
itself which to me was a good protest
obviously because you know fighting for
diversity is great
but
people have not forgotten that in the
black community so this is where the
discourse starts for us okay okay
so there we are viewing him as a
we
people love him i still think he's funny
he's talented all those things but we're
viewing him from that lens already
all right
so
the second layer of that situation is
in comedy
particularly black straight cis hat
communions in comedy
overwhelming
use jokes about black women
overwhelmingly
and they to get laughed and get a career
and he's one of them eddie murphy's one
of them it's a common trope i'm sure
you've heard of comedians being like my
black mom's like this my white moms like
this
dating a black girls like this
okay i mean like
i'm okay i'll take your word for it i
mean i'm not i haven't followed that
discourse i don't know what's the ratio
of jokes about black women and black men
sting or what
what which is what i'm saying because
i'm giving you a window to peer through
right now sure i i'm aware that you're
not aware okay i'm following yeah i'm
following this is discourse within the
black community amongst black men and
black women this has been a
long-standing discourse and it's one of
those things where a lot of black women
feel like it's reifying stereotypes
about us being loud and masculine
aggressive and ratchet and things like
that that are just not great because we
have to combat those stereotypes every
day i get it sounds like you know
um
a lot of black men dress up as black
women online
to be funny and be ratchet and stuff and
a lot of black women just don't like
that so again
so i understand all you're saying and
actually i get it right okay i'm getting
there i'm getting it i'm finishing up
don't okay go ahead
so in the context of the oscar situation
right
in the black community he's already
viewed a type away for the 2016 oscars
then he's making a joke about jada and
obviously her alopecia obviously not
life-threatening but she's been very
public about the emotional journey it's
taken her on those are her feelings i
get it it's not cancer whatever but
ultimately it's something that's
sensitive to her and it's something that
you know will seize from the back end
about what how do you even know chris
knew about it i mean i didn't know about
that
no i'm not saying he knew about it i'm
not saying it was deliberate i'm saying
that
ultimately
okay it's sensitive i get it for a very
long time right okay she's very
sensitive it's been public for a long
time it's like ever since she started
the red table talk she's been talking
about her losing hair okay so basically
at the end of the day whether you're
privy to that information or not it's
something that she's clearly and
publicly sensitive about
and to me
the joke was mid but it was in poor text
it's poor taste for sure especially and
so at what point are you justifying
will smith taking
there's a lot of layers it's a complex
there's lots of moving parts what i
think is what what a lot of black people
including myself are seeing is in this
sense it's
we're seeing a very particular type of
black entertainer and a different type
of black entertainer interacting
in a physical site and a lot of people
are on the side of will because
i broke down
how is it good to portray
like
you've got a disagreement right between
two black men yeah and you're saying
there's a lot of history behind it
how is one of them acting out in
violence in public a good perception for
humans or for black men or anyone i mean
this is the first thing we learn as kids
growing up is that you don't hit people
who say things to you you don't like i
mean stick rubber and glue and all that
[ __ ] right like i'm sorry but
i just don't understand knowing all that
okay
knowing all that yeah i just
don't understand how you could possibly
defend will this seems to me that it's
going to hurt the discourse
it's going to reinforce now
people are it's going to make people
more i i don't know i don't see how it
helps it just makes everything worse it
just seems horrible and he seems
unhinged it wasn't like a calculated
thing i mean i get it he's angry right
you've got all this history right he
just looks like an
unhinged lunatic
and then there's people just giving him
a standing ovation i mean what the [ __ ]
and what about i mean obviously
good good
you want to go you can go go ahead i'm
listening you want me to go
okay sorry obviously to you you know
what i mean it's definitely
that and i definitely agree
appropriately appropriateness not bare
definitely
all of the interaction the violence
definitely not appropriate i wouldn't do
it that's something that i think is you
know whatever and i also feel bad for
all the oscar winners because
unfortunately this was the first time
will packard was producing the oscars
i mean if you're worried about
stereotypes
i've heard
black comedians
and actors
and activists
acknowledge
there's this trope about like the
violent black man right he can't control
his temper
he's a violent black man and it's that
they say
that this is a harmful stereotype
so how the [ __ ] can people
defend will who seems to be embodying
that that stereotype like you're you're
changing out one stereotype for another
i wouldn't say i'm doing that i mean
you're entitled to your opinion what i
do think is
like i said at the beginning
definitely a choice was made i think
that at the end of the day he's gonna
have to face the consequences they're
talking about revoking his award and i
mean that's part of it you know what i
mean you decide to do something like
that on live tv open hands smack someone
in front of everyone on live tv you're
gonna deal with something and i you know
whatever it is whatever it is to be
honest
i
don't mind the fact that he slapped
chris rock i wanted to back a [ __ ] slap
chris rock a couple times over the years
and that's just my stance like obviously
a lot of people will read it as a
reinforcement of the angry black man the
violent black man black people are
savage
those stereotypes what i saw was a man
that was upset and defending his clearly
upset wife and i feel like you know
sometimes
violence happens i'm not gonna sit here
and say we live in a utopia i'm not
gonna sit here and say that people don't
get into fights people don't slap people
around sometimes
and i'm not gonna just you know say that
i think societally it's also
discussing appropriateness and who
decides what's appropriate and all of
those things and all of those
conversations that you know obviously
are you know for another day
first of all someone who is upset
i
appreciate you calling and sharing your
perspective i did learn a lot about the
backstory stuff yeah i really can't get
to understanding how justifying violence
is is okay and even if
there's all those layers of
stuff but
dan did you want to say something no no
it's okay
i don't know it i don't think it's
um
and i understand that ethan like
obviously this is you've made your
opinion clear i'm not coming on here to
try and change it quite obviously but i
mean i gave you a window to people i
appreciate it i i appreciate you gave me
a lot of information there that uh
that helps me thank you madison
no problem
bye guys
like okay there's a lot of history i
didn't i didn't know about the i didn't
think about it like the whole way of the
boycotting the black boy caught and he
was like yo [ __ ] this boy god
but you know
i just don't understand how it violence
is okay
i mean the precedent of people just
going and attacking comedians for doing
their job is just insane to me
it really is
it's just so [ __ ] crazy
keep [ __ ] my mouth he said
well anyway he went on to win the oscar
standing ovation he never apologized to
chris by the way he apologized to the
academy
here he is after
by the way his son tweeted and that's
how we do it
we attack people
i don't know it just seems trashy
i just don't get it i really don't
i mean she said she was happy he got
slapped in the mouth that scares me it
really does
i thought like as a society
we kind of moved past the violence for
jokes
the violence for comments
it's just crazy to me
my am i losing my mind
i don't know
you know
during the commercial break everyone's
everyone's comforting poor will smith
like am i [ __ ] crazy right now you
know
like chris rock's a legendary comedian
disrespected like that like he deserves
some respect
regardless of whatever you feel about
him
i didn't know there i didn't know the
black community apparently had a problem
with chris rock
that's news to me
but there it is
what am i looking at here's will denzel
and john tyler perry and tyler perry
you good dude i mean i don't know what
they're talking about but like
you know what about chris rock i mean
the [ __ ]
they're trying to calm down i get it
yeah that's fine
it's
complicated
what this moment or the thing
i mean it's not like my place to say
obviously but i you know from the black
community they're they're it's it's
probably hard for them to see that you
know they care for will they're trying
to look out for yeah i get watching him
maybe they're just friends yeah they're
watching his downfall live in front of
him it's sad to see you
king kong ain't got [ __ ] on me and tyler
perry and you know denzel are both very
big activists as well you know in that
community and it's rough
so it's always served as a you know a
great example of just a person in
general you know black or white
someone said oh my god it was a damn
slap over someone coming at a man a one
a man's wife who has a disease she's
struggling with and he has a history of
messing with people
okay he's made a gi jane joke he didn't
say look at this loser with alopecia
probably didn't even know she had it
and again
it's just a [ __ ] joke it's will smith
at the oscars it's not just a slap he
went up there and [ __ ] hit him in the
face
i just i i can't believe we're living in
a world where people are defending this
i didn't know the state i didn't
understand the state of our world was so
[ __ ] dilapidated where half of the
people seem to think that it's okay
for for this to have happened it it it's
i'm i'm
am i losing my mind
no i i genuinely
am [ __ ] blown away
i i don't know what to say
here the oscars go
am i crazy i mean what's going on here
does no one even want to speak uh back
me up i mean i get it if you don't i
don't know if apparently it's a
radioactive to say they're
it's yeah it's complicated it's it's not
right i mean no there's no excuse he's
in the wrong 100 there's no excuse for
violence
it's not complicated
it's not
violence is never the end i'm sorry it's
not complicated no he it's simple as
[ __ ]
no you're you're no i'm not simple as
[ __ ] i mean it's i'm afraid to speak
they don't because you know what i'm
saying don't [ __ ] mince words now you
just you just don't do that to people
especially in a setting like that i mean
you just you just don't just don't do
that
the man was hired to do a job
he said a tame [ __ ] joke
if you got a problem with the man that's
not how you deal with it
okay
it's simple [ __ ] arithmetic i don't
give a [ __ ] about their history or
whatever or anything you don't attack a
man for saying a tame [ __ ] joke like
that hell no like you said he could have
pulled him aside
after the fact
he could have roasted him in his speech
yeah but you know i'll tell you what
someone who's that quick to violence and
anger
it's so crazy like domestic abusers are
taking a big w tonight
they're like yeah
get super angry and can't control your
emotions you know the same people that
get violent like that over some [ __ ]
defending their wife are the same people
that get violent and anger at home when
arguing with their wife straight the
[ __ ] up that is not normal behavior
if you're violent like that you're
violent in other ways
period
i love the academy the academy does not
condone violence of any form
anyway tonight we're delighted to
celebrate our 24th academy winners
like what
tonight we are delighted to celebrate
our 94th academy winners who deserve
this moment of recognition from their
peers movie lovers around the world did
you find that [ __ ] insane retweet as
well the academy does not condone
violence of any form
anyway
you know um
yes you do
you literally do you literally let your
host who you hired who you have an
obligation to keep safe get punched in
the [ __ ] face let the
let the aggressor sit there and then
come up on stage and accept the award in
a standing ovation now you do condone
violence
well sorry also like
people to the side of the stage i mean
there's got to be security right of
course so
they saw that
and
i mean they kind of could have put two
and two together there you see will
smith coming up aggressively
i i get in a way because i think
everyone is
yeah i think everyone was confused about
what happened right up until the very
end yeah i think he i i would have
expected him to grab the mic and say
something you know
but it i do think they should have
kicked him out i mean nobody can do that
nobody can go attack the host of a
[ __ ] show
by the way it
i hate dude i hate these [ __ ]
arguments but like
i don't i just don't see how the this
history
of beef between them
justifies hitting him i don't
i get it if you got a problem talk about
it
it seems like you have a legitimate beef
and there's really a lot there to chew
on talk about it roast him expose him
how the [ __ ] does going up on stage and
slapping him help anything it makes you
look like a [ __ ] degenerate fragile
[ __ ]
especially when you're consistently
preaching for uh love not violence he
went up on stage and started crying
about how he's a vessel for love yeah
he's like you just slapped a man
five minutes ago he goes like he's
crying about being a vessel for love
well
i think he would argue that he did it to
defend the person that he loves
i'm not
agreeing with that but jesus loves and
he kills
well he also said denzel i killed
because i love
denzel told him don't let the devil
bring you down it was something along
the lines of that but i mean that he was
just violent man
don't let the devil bring you down i
mean he didn't want to take the role of
django and django unchained because he
said he doesn't believe in violence you
know people come off for that evening
samuel jackson's right next time
all these movies are violence you've
done like so many actions yeah
he it was specifically uh vengeance that
he he doesn't believe in vengeance he
doesn't believe in vengeance yeah
he said he said violence in movies was
fine
because i keep seeing that come up so i
checked out the clip of him this is an
act of vengeance so
well i guess that's a good thing isn't
it this is on the spot
it's true clearly
i'm sorry like i appreciate that caller
she gave me a
new perspective
i still don't understand this
can we do a poll i want to know how many
people watching think that it was
justified
maybe there's like yeah people are
saying i mean the real the real victim
of the night that nobody's talking about
is david dobrik i mean i really feel bad
for i know
uh you think he's doing okay today
well i just we need to analyze how this
is going to affect him
i mean i think that's the most important
thing to bear yeah that's true was the
slap justified
tell me what you guys think yes or no
okay good also i'm not losing my [ __ ]
mind
so that's a pretty early vote is pretty
overwhelmingly now
keep [ __ ] my wife's mouth this is a
woman by the way who has continually
disrespected him on her own show and by
the way sh i don't watch that show but
i've seen people say she talks [ __ ]
about people all the time on her show so
i'm sorry like i get it i talk a lot of
[ __ ] on the show and people say horrible
things about me online all the [ __ ]
time i'm not going to hunt them down
like taken people say horrible things
about my wife all the time i defend them
when i can't when when i when i have a
defensive defender with words i defend
her all the time i'm not going to go
[ __ ] track her down track them down
like taken and dump their bodies now if
chris rockefeller to get punched in the
face then ricky gervais's body should
have been dumped in the hudson river
i mean where do we draw the line he
deserved to get slapped okay do you guys
deserve to be punched in the stomach
did he deserve to get his arm cracked
really slap's fine he's just slapped
juliana thanks for the five dollar
donation uh she's defending will smith
like dan defended david what are the
reasons for the action important when it
was a white person but not now what the
[ __ ] are you talking about wait a little
bit i think she maybe she confused us
she is defending will smith like dan
defended david i
don't know what you're talking about
who's defending david and will smith
maybe they're talking about a b in the
forever ago like when the the thing the
first thing you're having how do you
bring that up i i defend the wrong
people like dan's always on the right
side of things
confused
yeah [ __ ] you baby i don't know what she
was talking i toned out when she said it
was for dan i'm sorry [ __ ] you both i'm
just i'm just covering my bases
thanks for the five bucks though
yeah sorry maybe donate another five to
clarify
you need to let the poll go longer the
polls still up yeah the poll's still up
82 is happening 16 000 votes i mean 20
is still scary but it's not as bad as it
sounds
yeah but if you guys can send your
thoughts and prayers to david you live
in a bubble around a bunch of yes ma'am
we [ __ ] just got
roasted
for disagreeing on this on the subreddit
like three days ago we we argue on the
show
literally all the time i just okay here
i'll take another caller from someone i
don't know if it's interesting like i
get the whole
backstory okay
now let's try to talk to
a guy
hopefully an alpha or something you want
to talk to a casey a chandler or
channing
what are you guys feeling what is this
those are all the calls we got
once from ohio india and chicago what do
you guys think what do you guys think oh
jennings sadler or casey
let's see
35 29 and
26
or no 23 29 to 26.
let's go with um
channing from chicago
channing talk to me
hi ethan longtime watcher and a fans
thank you so much
thank you for that you're a woman by the
way okay first i want to
oh yeah i'm sorry i i heard you wanted
to choose a guy but no i'm not a guy um
um first i want to start with what we
agree with i don't think that this
thought should have happened violence is
never the answer but
i feel like we should also be it was
very satisfying to get him watched i
mean to watch him get slapped personally
because okay this is the take on coming
from
the joke
was like you said if it was premeditated
there's more history there because okay
if you go back and you watch the 2016
oscars
the joke he made a joke about jada then
too and it was about how she wasn't
invited and how can it be a protest if
you didn't even think you weren't even
invited
so like who knows what's happened in the
five years since then what's happened
behind closed doors who cares another
thing that when people aren't saying
their peers their colleagues like
yeah who gives a [ __ ] he's [ __ ] fun
it was a conscious choice to make jada
the butt of his joke and it was about
her appearance he could have made a joke
about anything else but to make it about
somebody's appearance yeah who gives a
[ __ ] something that they can't change
about themselves this is okay this is
the same point people are making about
childhood posing you want to make people
the butt of your joke for how they look
for something that they can't change
about themselves
i mean it was a light it wasn't like a
brutal roast let's be honest he said gee
i i can't wait for gig too but to me
it's like okay
if you are watching somebody that you
know there's been animosity there before
and you see they make a conscious choice
you're saying he could have made a joke
about anybody on the front row
he could have made a joke about anyone
but he made it about jada he was talking
he was doing a bit about will and then
he acknowled basically it was not barely
a joke he was just acknowledging her it
was like a filler comment can't wait for
gi jane too
but to me it's like why her why make it
about her appearance and why make it in
front of thousands of people he like
publicly and especially if you watch how
he joked about her at the 2016 it's like
to me like i felt like we are missing
context like stuff has happened behind
closed doors we're watching the
culmination
of like because it's like like you said
for him to get to like get up there and
act like slap him on live tv like that's
that's big and so so you seem you seem
desperate to want to justify his action
like there must be a huge backstory
where it's somehow justified and not him
just be emotionally unstable
like i mean i don't think i mean like i
i to me yeah because it's like why else
would you why else because he's a
[ __ ] he's insane that's right
so what do you fantasize happen to
justified
what do you fantasize happen between
them
i just think that there's context
there's animosity there and i think he
watched him make
i don't know i don't i don't attack
people like this
should i go should i go hunt down
keemstar and [ __ ] him and and like
[ __ ] him up or something no and that's
what i'm saying i'm thinking it wasn't
he shouldn't have slapped him but okay
so then why so
the butt of his joke and will and i
think they're both wrong i think he
should have i think and i think in that
like but one is way more wrong when you
realize that he crossed he crossed a
line he realized he crossed the line and
so like neither one of them are right
i think it's gross that he made the joke
in the first place is what i'm saying i
think it wasn't that bad it really
like chris rock had a part in making a
documentary all about black women in
their relationship to their hair just to
get up yeah i've seen it good hair
yeah so it's like it's not so whether
you knew she had alopecia or not it's
like to make to like say that you're
conscious about
women and their relationship to their
hair just to get up on the oscar stage
in front of thousands of people and make
a woman in her hair the butt of your
joke
for what
to me it's like he made a bad choice and
so did will they both made a bad choice
it wasn't that bad i mean
one was way worse one was way worse it
wasn't they both made a bad choice
hold on hold on hold on hold on i let
you talk a lot i let you talk a lot
now listen
you could say and i'll give you this
that chris rock's joke wasn't bad taste
it wasn't a brutal [ __ ] joke
it was pretty tame but let's say it was
in bad taste and he shouldn't have done
it okay
okay bad choice
will smith going up and attacking him
apocalyptic insane thing to do now don't
be you can't say hold on hold on
you can't say
they both made a bad choice because that
is just a you putting them both on the
same place
because you're putting them both on the
same plane and they are not equally bad
it's just they are not equally bad what
will did was a gazillion times [ __ ]
more insane and worse you disagree
i don't know if he had like beat the
[ __ ] out of him maybe but like he
hit him in the [ __ ] face
he picked okay a bit slop he didn't take
it i'm actually like have you ever been
bitch-slapped
violent i haven't been [ __ ] clap okay
have you been slap by will smith
a massive [ __ ] strong dude
okay
when were you [ __ ] tell me about that
stuff and my friend
like in high school like if you say i
used to play basketball and like you
know by topic but someone [ __ ] slapped
you what'd you do
if my
he
like probably fouled the [ __ ] out of him
and then
you get in a fight okay so going up and
slapping he just gave him a little [ __ ]
slap so that was okay though if i said
something out of pocket if i said
something out of pocket about somebody
and they [ __ ] but me
i would think oh well maybe i deserved
that then i crossed the line like i
don't know like
he didn't like beat the [ __ ] out of him
yeah you're talking about a heist you're
talking about high school this is a
comedian a professional comedian who was
hired to go tell [ __ ] jokes at the
oscars where ribbing and roasting
celebrities is the norm will and jade
are sitting in the front row there's
going to be expectations that they're
going to have to swallow their pride for
one night and tolerate some light
ribbing which is all they [ __ ]
endured why then why did he why did
chris rock choose fine it was a bad joke
all right thank you channing i
appreciate you calling in
i just don't i don't get i don't get it
i don't get it
yeah
the consequence of this is [ __ ]
comedians now
are going to go to stand up and anytime
so much girl gets offended which by the
way these poor defenseless women
they need men to defend them do you not
feel insulted that you need a man you
can't speak for yourself you need a man
to [ __ ] stand up for you hey you
better not go to a comedy show by
yourself channing because god forbid the
comedian makes some joke about you what
are you gonna do if there's not a man up
there to go up and slap him in the
[ __ ] face oh it's just a [ __ ] slap
though so don't worry about it thank you
channing how are we going to do without
men
i think there's a difference between
saying that they both did something
wrong and then but at the same time i
feel like you're still trying to justify
what will did of course like you could
say like like you said it was a bad
taste and it was a bad taste and if
anything that's where i i feel like i'm
a little bit different i really think
what he said was really [ __ ] up but
there's it's like it was mildly [ __ ]
up
well i just think it's not for us to say
me personally because i come from a
muslim community and i know when girls
have to make that decision to cover
their hair that it is very hard on them
and they do feel
like hasn't she always had short hair
not to like justify i'm just genuinely
curious on the history i mean she's
always had short hair maybe she's been
dealing with it for a while i don't know
i'm not i'm not sure but
bro it's just but it's like saying okay
someone stomped on your toe and then you
shoot someone you know i mean it's it's
completely it doesn't you can't say they
both did something wrong you stepped on
his toe well the other guy shot you so
it's
it's a bad comparison well that's what
i'm saying too it's like it's like
you're stuck in this argument it's like
okay just [ __ ] slapped him yeah a 510
guy got [ __ ] slammed but [ __ ] slapped
by monster [ __ ] jacked will smith who
i've met in person he's huge and he's
strong
he played muhammad ali
um
yeah he played he played ali you know
the guy knows how to throw a punch the
dude dug into the earth like goku
channeling the [ __ ]
the powers of uh the universe fortnite
for a super attack
um
you can't say both were bad okay they
were not equally bad end a [ __ ]
debate
who else
okay let's talk to christina who i
think's on to something go ahead
christina
oh hi hi ethan um
i'm basically um
i don't even know how to start but
basically i want to say that i was
working a 12-hour shift yesterday when
my friend texted me about the whole will
smith thing she told me did i see it i
didn't have any context of what was
going on
so when i finally got home to watch it
i'm telling you in the back of my head i
was expecting him to say the worst
possible thing like i was like what
could have made will smith so mad
exactly that he went up on stage and
slapped him right so then i hear the
joke
and then i kind of like for a second i
was like was that it like i kind of
didn't understand why he would have been
so mad about it like you were saying you
know gi jane
um a strong powerful woman um jada smith
you know she would you would say she's a
strong beautiful woman right strong yeah
being bald powerful beautiful crazy
yeah so um she came out with her whole
alopecia story on instagram she shaved
her head on instagram and said she was
embracing her look okay so i was really
confused when will smith kind of like
went on stage and attacked him i felt
like it was kind of
like isn't she supposed to embrace being
called a strong bald woman right so i
think basically what the issue is i feel
like
that he was laughing right and he seen
jada's face and i feel like he had to
kind of
you know step up and show that
he is a man because you know with the
whole jada thing she's been over here
like
they have an open relationship and stuff
i don't know if that was necessarily
like will's choice
but um she just wanted to [ __ ] her son's
friends
yeah so i feel like they're basically he
was basically trying to not even defend
her necessarily bro she's not going to
[ __ ] you you know that meme yeah it's
like
i think she's not going to [ __ ] you bro
yeah i think he was just trying to
defend his manhood in
you're right you know i'm a man too i'm
strong i can 100 and the fact that it
was
yeah and the fact that it was another
black man i felt that's and i am okay
i'll say i'll preface this i'm a black
woman i'm mixed i'm black and white my
mom is black and my dad is white so when
i seen all this going on i know the
majority of people who are even watching
the oscars are white people so i feel
like just that alone kind of made the
scene kind of look bad like any time you
talk on like police violence or anything
white people turn around and say well
what about the black on black crime i
feel like that kind of just you know
just showed another kind of layer of
that like oh even in hollywood they get
down like that you know so i seen it and
then also i was thinking in the back of
my head i'm like
i'm not sure if you're aware but chris
rock made this documentary um it's
called good hair
a journey of a black woman yeah good
hair it's a it's a documentary about you
know black women's journey getting their
hair done i don't think the joke was
made to you know come at her for being
bald i think it was just to say you know
you're a strong bald black woman like
that's it you're a strong woman so i
feel like the whole thing with will is
it's just really sad honestly it's like
really pitiful and seeing it from a
black person's perspective i feel like
he really has fallen and him doing that
was trying to you know
prove a point basically i don't think he
i don't think there was a reason for him
to do it i think if jimmy kimmel would
have made a joke i think honestly if
jimmy kimmel would have made a joke or
something like that it would have been a
thousand times worse but i don't think
will would have gotten on stage
and
i know people are saying like don't make
it a black thing don't make it a race
thing but it's not even about that i
think it's just that will has been
stepped on so much that when he sees the
opportunity to you know take out some
anger on somebody he's going to do it
you nailed it
the thing is who's this about you're
exactly right i've been arguing with
people on my facebook about it it's just
really sad because i do see people
they're like oh um that's what you're
supposed to do for your wife this and
that since we also have to look at the
other hand yeah you have to look at the
other hand she
every day on her show i don't know if
it's every day but all the time on her
show she's making digs at will smith
she's bringing down his you know legacy
in a way and i feel like i don't know
what it is but i feel like they just
need to divorce separate i don't know
but it's just really sad seeing him fall
so far so
that's exactly
you're exactly right she has publicly
humiliated him on her show on a regular
basis he's questioning himself his
legacy his manhood he's lashing out he's
angry at her
he's angry
that his legacy is being tarnished by
his wife who's somehow made made herself
relevant by [ __ ] on him right and
and he and he is he's definitely lashing
out
because of what she's done to him it's
it's it seems so obvious i mean you can
see it you can see it alone when you
watch she's laughing
she's upset and then he goes oh i better
do something like like he's laughing
i feel like i feel like he was laughing
and then there's like this meme going
around on the internet that like when
the cameras went off on him he was like
no jada told him like oh you thought
that was funny well you think it's funny
that's why i went out and cheated and
got like went with other men you know so
i don't know what was that i don't know
if she kicked his leg or something and
was like hey go do something but i just
feel like it all was just so uncalled
for it and at the end of the day it just
makes black people look bad like that's
not the setting where you're supposed to
see something like that it's like
it just was really bad like even the
whole like part after when he was like
accepting his award and stuff i seen it
i was like this is so freaking cringe
like what does the devil have to do with
it and that's another thing like i know
the black community we always got to
bring the devil into it always got to
bring like you know god into everything
but it's like i was thinking i was like
will like you were the devil like you
were the violent one you were the one
that you know
brought out that bad energy i i don't
know it's just really sad i hope that
will
i don't know and you know too another
thing is like at these award shows
they're giving out liquor you know who
knows what he's on just to you know
deal with the pressure of being in
hollywood it's like he probably just
snapped and
i don't know i hope everything's okay
with him though i definitely am still
rooting for him i want him to you know
be be happy and be a good figure in the
black community everybody looks up to
him listen my concern is like
i agree right like it's okay to root for
him to recover
and stuff yeah like everything you've
said
i agree with you're right on point
christina but the part that concerns me
is the amount of people who are
reinforcing his behavior and saying this
was good because he is not going to
learn the right lesson from this
if everyone's telling him that was the
right thing to do and there's a lot of
people out there who are watching who
are not going to [ __ ] get the right
message out of this situation either
that's the part that's really disturbing
me is the amount of people supporting
him
and i would say from that perspective i
say that we have to look at like what
will has been through like like i'm
saying i don't think he was even
defending jada at that point i think he
was defending himself totally like
it wasn't even a it wasn't even a good
joke i didn't laugh it wasn't funny at
all it wasn't meant to be a joke that
was a problem you know if the joke was
funny then a lot more people would
probably be defending chris rock right
now
was it a good
even funny i'm saying i don't even think
it was supposed to be made as a joke i
think it was supposed to be like a
comparison and that's what i was talking
to some of my friends on facebook about
i'm i've been commenting on their stuff
all day and it's just like you can tell
people
you know that part of it that it wasn't
even supposed to be a joke to begin with
but when they have it dead set in their
mind like no he was coming at her hair
no this and that i'm like why would a
man who made an hour and a half
documentary about black women's hair
because his child is black it's not like
he has a mixed baby or nothing i'm
pretty sure his daughter is 100 black
has nappy hair you know so it's like why
would he knowing what black women go
through for their hair
try to come at her as a hair joke i
don't think it was like that right
there's a lot of assumptions being made
you know about his intentions at a
simple [ __ ] like
a filler line you know i mean people are
really assuming a lot on chris rock
there yeah
and even if you assumed the worst it's
still not acceptable that's the thing
you know
yeah definitely not and i don't know
it's just it could have been handled so
differently i think maybe like i feel
like jada should have seen him going up
there and as a wife i feel like that's
where she should have stepped in and see
he wanted him to do it upset about it
yeah like but that yeah and that's what
i'm saying so it's like obviously
there's two parts of the situation like
she probably was egging him on we don't
know what was you know happening and
stuff but it's like i feel like if that
was my husband and somebody made a joke
about my hair or something it and she
supposedly in air quote she's embracing
it right she's talking about you know
she's proud of it and all this and that
then why would you let your husband go
up there and make it look like you're
something it's something that you're
ashamed i know eva wouldn't want me to
go attack someone for making a joke
about her like that's humiliating it's
embarrassing that's not what a real man
does i'm sorry it's just not
yeah and i think it all comes down to um
jada has control like i think she is a
manipulator i think she's controlling
and before i did not have this opinion
of her i i liked her actually but now
after seeing all of this seeing how
stupid she made him look i just feel
really bad for the both of them it's
like she gets off on humiliating man
100
yeah like if this went on at a show like
imagine what it is at home like
that's what i'm saying
dude violence of any kind is so damaging
to everyone around you it doesn't matter
who it's targeted against that's what
i'm saying imagine what he's like at
home if he's this violent i'm not even
i'm not even talking about will like i
definitely i don't know about how he is
at home i hope i hope and pray that he's
really not like that 100 i hope not um
but i'm just saying like jada i feel
like jada is a manipulator like the fact
that she
yeah the fact that she was able to do
something and have him get that irate
you know in such a such a formal setting
like everybody's wearing tuxedos and
stuff like you you have to be a master
manipulator and that's where it's like i
feel like they're definitely not healthy
for each other they just need to
separate and the fact that um jaden
smith you know tweeted that out after
it's kind of just like what do you say
that's how we do it
yeah like look that's a bad example that
you're putting on for yourself bro it's
so bad
yeah like that's not okay especially
when they're coming from money it's kind
of sad because um i was hearing that
chris rock didn't press charges i wish
he did and i feel like like i was going
back to saying that if it was a white
person they would have pressed charges i
feel like will knew in the back of his
mind nothing was really going to come
out of this and i feel like if it was
somebody else something you know he
would have gotten real consequences
well i understand chris rock putting in
a tough position because if he press
charges he looks bad i think what chris
rock needs is he looks bad right like
it's like snitching or something
he does look bad but it's not snitching
it's like it's it wasn't even a joke the
joke wasn't funny it wasn't a joke it
was a comparison like
i don't see anything wrong
with what he said and i'm i'm gonna be
quite honest i feel like he should have
the way that will reacted i feel like he
actually should have went in on her
because it's like if he would have went
in on her at least the joke would have
been funny like he would have got
something out of it he didn't even get
to say he did a good joke like he just
got slapped in the face no i know that's
the worst part that's that's the worst
part for chris yeah honestly i feel bad
for chris he got humiliated on a public
stage and almost nobody [ __ ] cares
um where's his respect i don't care
thank you you know what definitely this
is such a great call
christina thank you so much it's so nice
to hear your your perspective
thank you so much for taking my call
really fast i want to say it's christina
with a k to the chat but thank you so
much for taking my call thank you
everybody i agree with most of the stuff
you say 100
thank you but um yeah i hope you guys
have a good day thank you quinn
great thank you bye-bye
she couldn't have said i couldn't say it
myself
totally over compensating for his wife
weakly humiliating that man
here's jaden smith
who by the way
do people respect him as a musician i
don't want to talk out of school but
he's a kid it's the most privileged
little [ __ ] of all time he's a [ __ ]
pseudo-intellectual
[ __ ] loser [ __ ] him too and that
whole damn family
and she scares me bro
who
his wife jada
she's right man
the way she flipped that man into a
frenzy in like a split second was wild
dude was laughing
you know what i'm saying still though i
mean it's his decision i don't think he
should no i agree but like i think it
they both came out looking bad
you know i do
well they're a unit and you know the
the family seems to be in solidarity
based off of uh
and that's how we do it
well there you go we got a we've got a
whole slew of perspectives there
you [ __ ] in my mouth
is what jada says to uh
her son's
what the friends dude oh my god that's
pretty that's pretty rough
um
let's see
yeah saying no willow slander that's
true i don't think willows i didn't say
anything about willow
well you said the whole family yeah
you're right i like willow she seems
nice and fine and she hasn't caught she
yeah knows willow slander you're right i
like willow
jaden is obnoxious little [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] head though
you don't i don't like him am i supposed
to like him
i thought we all agreed he was like
obnoxious and all of a sudden people
used to do i mean
i know that now he puts out music and
did i hear
there are some
jaden smith music fans yeah i like his
music okay just to be honest i i don't i
haven't heard any of it um i i just know
him from yeah his uh
deep thoughts yeah that he used to tweet
all the time
oh av dug up a little interesting nugget
apparently
will smith
where'd that go it'd be
oh i didn't want to confuse you i
deleted it but um
you talking about when he was 15 yeah
yeah so when will smith was 15 he said
that well he said when he was 15 his
first girlfriend cheated on him and
that's what made him want to be the
number one actor in the world he's like
he felt like some part of him
had to prove to the world that no one's
going to cheat on him again and he's and
there you go he married a woman who
ended up not only cheating on him but
[ __ ] her
son's friend bro dude that's so much
worse and is what his masculinity in his
mind
is you know
under attack
and he's lashing out so obvious
tiffany haddish who is this by the way
she's a comedian
here she is
here she is um what has she been in i
don't
don't bunch of stuff
really she was in that eric andre movie
bad trick oh for real yeah
this is great she made a statement
that's just like so bad [ __ ]
she said
i went up to her and said you better
suck his dick from the back girl what
does that mean
what do you mean what does that mean to
suck someone's dick from the back
like to bend it backwards i guess like
it's between the legs i don't like back
behind no not a good necessarily i'll
take a normal one thank you that's
exactly right nanny kid
all fours i'll i'll take a normal one
please
yeah
she's still not putting out
another joke i saw was jade is like yeah
well tupac would have killed him so i'm
not still not [ __ ] you not impressed
apparently she dated tupac right yeah
yeah will smith has been open about that
too how when he was younger he was so
jealous of tupac because of the
relationship that jade and tupac had
wait weren't they friends though or they
were co-stars they did a movie together
i believe so he yeah so he has a lot
he's very possessive and he has a lot of
built up
animosity with his wife's relationships
with people
you know
dude needs therapy not not an oscar
i think he's in it
not a lot of people well well
scientology doesn't count okay
that doesn't count as a therapy
somebody
came out and said uh made a statement
that um
apparently they broke uh
their association with scientology uh
about 67 years ago when it was bad pr
they quote broke their
association right
that's my take i'm sorry i'm just seeing
that they were really good friends i
guess they weren't co-stars
um here's what tiffany
haddish said when i saw a black man
study up for his wife that meant so much
to me
as a woman who has been unprotected
for someone to say like keep my wife's
name out of your mouth leave my life
alone that's what your husband is
supposed to do right protect you
and that meant the world to me
maybe the world might not like how it
went down but for me it was the most
beautiful thing i have ever seen
because it made me believe that there
are still men out there that love and
care about their women and their wives
well i'm sorry to tell you but i'm
pretty sure he just did that because
again as the last scholar said i don't
think it was an act of love i think it
was an act of uh
[ __ ] just
desperation and like
i don't know
that's hot but to call that the most
beautiful thing you've ever seen
i mean like where's my prince charming
if you subtract if you subtract the the
slap out of it um i could definitely
understand that because you can defend
your wife classy lee right right i feel
like i defend ila all the time okay yeah
i mean don't you could stand up for your
woman without resorting to violence yeah
if you just went if you if you went
rewind time for a second
and just
take take the part of that whole
exchange where he walked up onto the
stage and slapped him out and just if he
even screamed yeah
and he was angry then i think even
people would be like absolutely that was
that was nice or again if when he had
won he had gone up and called him out
and and said specifically why that was
so upsetting yeah you're ignoring the
there's a lot of ways that that could
have been handled where he would have
looked great right honestly right right
yeah and i i think
she's ignoring the most significant part
of what happened the violence yeah
it was the most beautiful thing i'd ever
seen yeah
yeah
oh our ticked we did a tick tock bear do
you guys want to
bump it up
here post me a link yeah fortnight
i don't know man i'm like bro i didn't
realize our our civil civilization was
so [ __ ] backwards that this was like
normal i mean i've just been losing my
mind
here yeah to be i'll be honest with you
ethan when i saw your tweets last night
i thought
though i don't disagree with your take i
thought you were
not overreacting but uh uh
wording things too harshly i guess you
could say
and um coming today
i'm sorry
i just there's a little audio in the
background uh and it really wasn't until
this morning i don't know it just
randomly hit me i remembered
that um
you know it was not two weeks ago that a
unstable person uh stalked you
um for lightly ribbing them
into my house and i took my address and
people that think that ethan is
overreacting here um i would just keep
that in mind and and not only that but
that's far from the first time um
that people have
come for ethan with violence um it it
happens more than i think our audience
even watches we don't know we've bombed
threats i'll be your will smith yeah
i'll swipe the [ __ ] out of something and
so something about you know um thank you
doug
because i do see a lot of takes of
people like oh
these comedians uh you know are so
fragile that it's just like oh somebody
finally like stood up to them but
you know when it's you when it's you and
your family who is being threatened with
physical violence for for light violence
or for light ribbing
um i can understand why seeing that and
seeing so many people defending what
will smith do uh did would be upsetting
look i'm friends with comedian yeah i've
been the subject of this [ __ ]
i'm sorry what the [ __ ] are we talking
about
guys
this is insane here check this out i
don't i haven't seen this yet let's see
how it turned out ethan is ela coming
today
keep my wife's name out your [ __ ]
mouth
dude
is she coming it's a simple question
okay what what
nice
it turned out pretty good all right
there you go
that's how i handle myself now boy
i'll just be carrying a glove
going fisticuffs all day that's society
we all want to live in huh just smack
the [ __ ] out of me
there's another donation said stop
blaming women for the actions of men uh
you know i i kind of agree i i i pushed
back a little bit earlier um
no matter how many times for the actions
event okay no matter how manipulative
jada is will didn't need to do that you
know
be a man be the bigger man you know what
i mean and again there's just like there
were ways out of that
there was could have been so much class
here that would have
really made him look really good and and
he chose the low road and
you know there are a lot of people
defending him but i think there's i'm
sorry a lot of people who started for
him went down too and i mean our poll is
over 40 000 votes
80 saying no it was not justified for
that
i feel like
civilization took a massive l that night
like we are not [ __ ] cavemen guys
this is like we don't work society
doesn't work when we are this readily
violent with each other it's just not
how it works will smith was our harvey
dent he was the best of us
and he now he went rogue man it's true
he's supposed to be a class act right
okay i won't blame mint i won't blame uh
i won't blame her for what he did go on
full joker and you're right because this
whole thing reeks of of kind of like a
weird misogyny of like and you need your
man to defend you
right and i think you make a good point
with that so let's not go the other
direction and blame jada for him
you know let's not
here's a bunch of
tweets of people defending will that was
just blowing my goddamn mind all night
just whoa
many things don't hear about will smith
the chris augustine people whose
partners are not black women
mainly white people
i just i don't understand how people
turn it into a race thing
it's two black guys okay first of all so
like it's just weird to me
people are so desperate to turn it into
a race thing it's because it it's
related to hair and that is a specific
sore spot with black women and so
but
look right it is
guys there is the dynamic where it's
the person making the comment is also a
black man who has been an activist in
that exact space and um you know it
wasn't until our last caller
uh was pointing out that she didn't
think that it was even supposed to be an
insult
i'd have to watch it again but she might
be right like it might have just let's
pull up that that small moment
and let's just watch
because it was such a throwaway comment
yeah it may it may well have been well
let's make a judgment here
he says i don't care if it's a joke or
not the amount of black women have
endured people are tired of it we have
no idea what jada has gone through
dude i just i'm sorry that might still
be true
but it just doesn't justify
g.i jane 2 can't wait to see it all
right
chris look at how he loves the joke go
back go back
don't show too much don't shoot too much
go back go back to the beginning
i want to see that again let's let's
really analyze this
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
okay says jada i love you
gi jane
jane 2 can't wait to see it
yeah i mean it's
yeah it's open for interpretation yeah
it's not brutal
and
it's just not that [ __ ] bad
i mean if he picked like a more
if he picked a different character i
don't know what's like a stereotype for
like a a bald woman
uh but like that's not a bad stereotype
gi jane
it's just not like it's the joke about
being bald obviously there so i don't
know what his intentions are but that is
a good character
so
it wasn't like i can't wait to see the
movie about the jizz lane maxwell or if
she was bald or something that would be
worse
if it was a white guy making the joke
it'd be way worse then it's a different
situation if there's a white guy making
a joke i think we'd be [ __ ] and uh
oh boy be a lot of fallout a lot more
fall out
i do understand the backlash when some
people are like oh she could just wear a
wig it's like in that situation like
would you be saying that if it was
a white actress would you be saying oh
just wear a wig so that if people are
saying that i can understand the
pushback i didn't hear anyone saying
just wear a wig
that's a stupid comment i mean that
saying that comment is obviously dumb
yeah not defending anyone saying that
so i don't
know here let's keep going
will smith said not today
a man big enough to absolutely floor him
slapped him softly enough that chris
barely moved
because he made fun of his wife's
alopecia on a world stage
don't say protect black women for two
years and then only condemn will here i
don't know if that's the way
is that how we're protecting black women
by being violent
like i'm sorry
the most disrespectful person in america
is the black woman most unprotect this
is a a malcolm x quote the most
unprotected woman in america is the
black woman the most neglected person in
america is a black woman
i don't i first of all
i agree it's a great quote and i agree
with the message
but but you know violence is not it okay
those defending will smith as you should
please keep that same energy for the
countless black women transgender people
and others who are often harassed and
humiliated in the names of jokes
okay so
yeah there you go fight comedians
i mean
so there seems to be just
people were like when chappelle was
doing all this trans jokes
and trans people
nobody went up there and punched him in
the face by the way
but they were making some there was like
backlash right online
right
and it just seems like a lot of the same
people were like it's just a joke
everyone gets joked about
i don't know if it was the same people
what i find so interesting about this
one is i i
you know
a lot of this culture war stuff has
become so predictable
with there's everything so polarized you
got you got the lefties and the righties
and they always kind of
coalesce into their takes uh
i haven't really seen it coalesce in the
same way i've seen people on the left on
both sides of this argument i've seen
people on the right on both sides of
this argument um
i don't know
for whatever reason i don't
see this falling into the same
categories that most
kind of
social discourse topics do
i hate to say it but
i think i see mostly people on the woke
left
justifying the violence
i hate to say it
but that's who i see almost exclusively
justifying the violence yeah but is it
like the first caller where it's
where are you seeing that on twitter i
mean it
here's nicki minaj
she woke i don't think i don't know
about that yeah i don't know
probably not
is she the one that admitted to like
drugging dudes and stealing their money
uh that was actually cardi b oh [ __ ] i
think nicki minaj was she was anti-vaxx
yes
minaj is very loudly antibacterial so
actually
opposite spectrum
the walk right i believe you call them
she's based her cousin has stolen balls
right oh blah blah blah yeah the cousin
woke up from barbados
yeah yeah
wow a nice little crosstalk where did
her cousin from where did she say
trinidad or something
coconuts
right
in coconut and barbados
everybody's saying dan adds dan ads for
the last hour we did our ad it was at
the beginning episode that's the yeah
that we had thank you guys thank you so
much thank you guys thank you very much
shout out to good work we did just a
short one at the top that was the deal
that's it thank you for reminding us
though appreciate y'all really caring
i do it's really thoughtful
just gotta you just got to witness in
real time what happens in a man's soul
when he looks over the woman he loves
and sees her holding back tears from a
little joke at her expense this is what
any and every real man feels in that
instant
well you all see the joke she's seeing
her pain
the husband gets a front row seat to his
wife pain he's the one consoling her
drying her tears behind closed doors
when those cameras go off social media
has made people feel that these husbands
won't ever run into them in real life
imagine what it must feel like to be
losing your hair to the point where you
have to shave it bald you think that's
easy to deal with for anyone you don't
think she's cried about it many times
2022 you're gonna have to see these men
about these jokes you made about their
wives
oh this is not again like this is not
someone on the street
being like hey what's up gi jane or
whatever to her face just to make a j
this is a comedian at the oscars being
hired
pre-screened pre-written jokes
you're a [ __ ] the most famous
powerful couple in hollywood in the
front stage you're gonna have to come
down and be a human for the day okay
it's not it's just not that it's just
not that okay
go ahead dan
oh i was gonna say is
all these takes
again if it was just the part where he
said shut the [ __ ] up about my wife
i would probably agree with it
but people just seem really willing to
shrug it off
you know i guess to a lot of people it's
just like oh it's just a slap which is
you know chris is chris rock's gonna be
fine it's it's true it's not a big deal
hit him in the face i agree but i mean
it's just it's the act of violence okay
i i agree with that too that now is
normalized but that's why i think in a
lot of you know if you come up there and
beat him within an inch of his life i
doubt there would be as many people
defending but i think to a lot of people
it's like it's just a slap
you know but it's just so insane it's
just a slap
so where's the line
right yeah no i mean the the line is
don't don't hit people for for mildly
rib did we learn that first grade rubber
and glue yeah whatever you say i'm not
even
got him what happened to that
and jaden smith of course and that's how
we do it
yeah i'd like to see jaden smith try to
have a music career born when like
having being grown up in a like normal
[ __ ] urban family
yeah you still be on soundcloud with a
thousand followers
[ __ ] you less
30.
love says his music's fine yeah it might
be fine
yeah he might be a good musician there's
a lot of great musicians that never get
to get their music about there's
probably there's probably tens of
thousands of better musicians than him
that will never get the exposure they
deserve because they're not will smith's
son so shut the [ __ ] up jaden
just be happy that you're
the most privileged person alive
that's probably not true close to
but yes who's more privileged than
jayden anyone that's rich and white yeah
okay fair enough
definitely
chris jokes chris rock's one joke was
rooted in misogyny texturism what's
texturism
and ableism come on
and it's misogynouire
oh misogyny noir i think whoa
specifically we're in the [ __ ]
mainframe uh what's texturism
i gotta say that's a new one for me is
the idea that only loose or well-defined
curls deserve favoring or whatever it
has to do with hair
wait to read that again abby
uh texturism is the idea that only loose
or well-defined curls deserve favoring
or praise and it manifests in the
smallest ways within the natural hair
community okay so the light curls is
what's up
but he didn't mention her curl uh
tightness
but again they're saying that it's
rooted in it which means you know she
doesn't have it it's part of this wider
and what's misogyny newer
uh
well contextually i would imagine it's
black
misogyny
noir means
okay misogyny noir
texturism and are we gonna enable this
might know that one are we going to give
them ableism
from
a disability that seems i mean it seems
like a stretch there i mean it's a
condition it's a medical condition uh i
don't think it's necessarily i mean
okay so somebody's a paraplegic right
and someone has alopecia
okay
yeah i mean let's let's let's tighten up
the definition there a little bit right
yeah
right
i mean imagine someone a paraplegic and
they have to [ __ ] blow into a straw
to move around
he's like i he's like i'm disabled and
then jadis smith comes in
she goes i am also disabled
by the way well massage noir is misogyny
directed towards black women
where race where race and gender both
play roles in the bias okay that's valid
[Music]
ableism i'm gonna i'm gonna
i think
as a man with tourettes
i think i'm more entitled to the ableism
uh
than even her
i have a neurological disorder she's
just losing her hair i mean you want to
do the olympics let's [ __ ] go
and anyone who talks [ __ ] about my
tourette's i'm coming i'm gonna i'm
gonna bomb your house
just kidding i'm not gonna do that
i'm just kidding please don't
that's not a serious not a serious
threat youtube i would never do that
jokes are not violence
minstrel shows were just jokes
i mean okay
blackface is just jokes please stop with
this [ __ ]
i mean
okay
some people have a broad definition of
violence and like okay i i i will grant
that some jokes go too far
but guys let's not lose sight all he
said was that i
i love you and i can't wait for gi joe
too
jane gi jane too but let's just not lose
sight of what he said
now there are jokes that go too far
you know
granted
you know if he was like hey let me smell
your breath smells like uh your son's
dicks uh it smells like your son's dick
now give your husband a kiss let him
taste it
too far i would probably be consistent
he didn't say that
you know what i mean like it was tame
that's it that's all we got
did you guys have this put out a
statement
wait who just put it out will smith okay
interesting this is good this is live
live right now will smith statement
you see where
ian
somebody in the chat we got a statement
boys
ladies and gents
uh
here we go i think i just found it
[Music]
well wait who tweeted this nicole
spurling is this someone's
just sharing it but
violence nice breaking news
oh breaking news will smith has put out
a statement here we go folks
[Music]
violence in all of its forms is
poisonous and destructive
my behavior at last night's academy
awards was unacceptable and excusable
jokes that jokes at my expense are part
of the job but a joke about jada's
medical condition was too much for me to
bear and i reacted emotionally
well he was laughing at first am i is it
like it might is it possible that it was
sometimes you laugh when you're
uncomfortable yeah okay you just laugh a
little bit and then you realize you're
offended yep
okay i would like to publicly apologize
to you chris
i was out of line and i was wrong i
embarrassed and my actions were not
indicative of the man i want to be
there is no place
for violence in a world of love and
kindness
i'd also like to apologize to the
academy
the producers of the show
all the attendees and everyone watching
around the world i would like to
apologize to the williams family
the williams family yeah because he won
the award for best actor for king
richard which was about the williams
family okay
and my king richard family
i deeply regret that my behavior has
stained what has been an
otherwise gorgeous journey for all of us
i am a work in progress okay pretty good
apology pretty good apology yeah i like
that
we like that
and at what point is this sun gonna roll
back the this is how we do it because
they seem to be at odds with each other
right this statement in his
so everybody in chat saying that he was
totally justified in doing it
what do you think now that he just
said that violence is not uh
justifiable in this situation
ratio
i'm not even saying that to be smarmy
but it's just like
even even he feels that way so i know
it's a little weird to
be defending him on his actions on his
behalf when he doesn't even stand behind
it go off king that was a great apology
i'm glad
he owned it and said
the right thing which is that violence
is not the [ __ ] if violence in all forms
is poisonous and destructive that's a
great statement and i that i totally
agree with
you know
like damn how we gonna move forward in a
society where that's not obvious to
everyone we need that we need that
violence in all forms is poisonous and
destructive
that's good you see and just like that
i have in my heart
forgiven will
in a little bit in a little bit of a way
we're on the road to repair
you guys want a poll what kind of poll
like i mean obviously it's a good
apology you guys want to know if it was
a good apology i mean it was it seems
like most people say that i think it's
pretty
do we want it
i mean it's up to chris so painfully
white and that's coming from a white
person yeah wait what'd you say
i was just reading and calling read it
again y'all are so painfully white and
that's coming from a white person well
how else am i supposed to be yeah so
that's literally i'm a white dude you
want me to be black
that would be odd that would be you
would not like that you would like that
less ethan refuses to listen to black
voices we
bro i had like black women called in on
this the [ __ ] up two out of the three
callers we're black women and we had
good i listened to all of them
stop trying to make i'm
stop dude what the [ __ ] bro
ethan's racist because he
i don't know i've lost the plot on that
on that talking point
i am of course
a white supremacist
okay someone said i'm really
disappointed at the idea that somehow
him slapping someone in defense of his
wife is proof the abuser i never said
it's proof and i don't think it's proof
but it's proof that he's violent uh
and if someone is so ready to use
violence
at being angry then he's more likely to
use violence in the comfort and ease of
his own home because you know when
people are at home they are way more
comfortable to act out in ways they
wouldn't in public especially on the
stage at the academy awards when someone
gets angry like that they're way more
likely to get violent and angry in other
walks of their life including with their
kids their daughters or their i mean
their children or anyone else it's just
the fact and that's why i like what he
really said which is violence in all
forms is poison is destructive it is
period
thank you next
anyway apologies to david dilbert
because we really need
i don't know how this can affect david i
know
well i don't even want to joke about
defending him because apparently some
people thought me saying that
he's
uh
mentally ill is uh defending him yeah
you gotta wait what did i say
no somebody earlier remember that they
were donating over and over again saying
i was defending him wait miss democracy
oh no we're not defending david we're
making a dumbass journal
making a joke because he made all this
[ __ ] all the bad things happened to the
victims he made himself the victim
oh someone said the apologies [ __ ] i
don't buy it i think he wrote posted it
because it's bad publicity otherwise
well it's definitely bad publicity but
regardless of if you think it's genuine
or not at least what he wrote is good
because like a lot of times people will
apologize and they'll be like
you know
there was a little bit in there which i
think
could have been removed
if you pull up the apology again
he does attempt to justify the punch
by saying i couldn't tolerate to have my
wife but like i don't know if he just he
qualified he does a little he does a
little he leaves a little room for
supporters
you know to be like seemed more like he
was ex i mean he said that he yeah the
comment made him emotional and he
overreacted i don't think that that's
done pulled up again he said he has to
explain himself to a degree yeah
i was out of line i was embarrassed
i think it's on the way here jokes at my
expense are part of the job but a joke
about jada's medical condition was too
much for me to bear
he says jokes about me are okay but
jokes about my wife are too much for me
to bear i mean she's also a public
figure bro
like i'm sorry
you know whatever but it's a good
apology on whole my wife went out for
pizza without me there's there's been
way worse apologies than no it's a great
apology i think he said the right thing
whether it was for pr or whatever who
gives a [ __ ]
anyway anyone checking with david
david's like i was supposed to host
these off this oscar event i was
supposed to be there for for uh
twitter's choice man did you guys see
that they started taking the oscars is
[ __ ] dead
bro i'm so over them
who care i'm tired of [ __ ] licking
the boots of these rich and famous [ __ ]
like you just act dude it's not that
important to begin with i'm sorry
like cool it's good you guys are really
good at your job that's awesome
it's just not that [ __ ] important i
can't deal with all these these
celebrities up there acting like they're
[ __ ] saving the world by acting dude
i'm sorry i'm just so over there it's
just like god lee they're so out of
touch bro where's the award show for
like best [ __ ] uh
you know
what
why do they get an award show where's
everyone else's awards you know yeah no
i don't disagree like yeah the oscars
suck you're not gonna get a defense from
me but i'm just tired of this they're so
self-important yeah it doesn't need to
be the spectacle like
it's an industry award for
you know them to pat each other on the
back for a job well done which isn't in
itself
a bad thing but yeah it's just treating
it with such reverences yeah people say
you're rich i know i'm rich what's
what's your [ __ ] point
and i wasn't born into wealth like jaden
was
not that that's a bad you know what
stop when i'm ahead
do you want me not to talk because i'm
rich
okay delete me from this conversation
yeah
chuck what's your opinion
what's ja rule what is a jaw rules
opinion on this actually does he tweeted
about it let's see
do you have a twitter i'd call that uh
assault
is it raining it's like pouring outside
right now
just seeing
yeah we need to rewatch ricky gervais
his speech
he needs to be cut into like tiny bot
pieces and spread across the goddamn
gulf of mexico or some [ __ ] rules uh
rocking one of those nft profile
pictures he is yo this guy never misses
he went straight from firefest to uh the
world new nft project profile what the
[ __ ] is this dude world of women galaxy
yo
let's think of how to dig
ourselves fraud
what so he hasn't tweeted about it
damn
what's he waiting for go to his tweets
and reply slapping season is officially
in session okay there we go
okay so yes comment so there you go now
we have the official record we have the
official response from joe rule
go to his like tweets let's see what
he's liking let's not let's do a deep
dive man i want to know what he thinks
about this for like i want to get into
his mind
i want to see what jaw rule is liking
god
come on now i'm scared to do this live
to be honest you never know what you're
going to get in the in the twitter likes
okay well do it off screen and then tell
me if there's anything good
i don't think jarrow's like anything
well he's mostly just like nft [ __ ] yeah
you're right okay a bunch of board apes
stuff all right job roll
that could be a good uh transition
because we do have an nft story uh
you guys are over it that's fair
i mean what we've said it all we've
covered it all some great calls
actually
diverse opinions
and also i was happy to get some some
black people's opinions uh we had a few
and i thought it was great women
actually no man shared his opinion turns
out i tried to get one but it was a
woman
but
women
opinions are great and we love them here
on this show
i will love
women in fact we love them more because
the majority of our viewers are women
by about 60 percent
we love our women actually
i love their opinions about 60 percent
more than limit
so i'm glad they were all women
you know
you could just call it too because my
throat is [ __ ] and i need a break but
i mean there's so many good stuff let's
see let's let's do a tease for next week
um that's pretty epic we talked about
that for two hours though
so we got to talk about your boxing
event
we got to talk about
dude
faze blanks called out david david
dolbrick has fallen off so hard this man
is running like he's involved in a
crypto scam called board bunny nft
down bad
and getting called out by phase blanks
these blanks of all people
there's three h3 humor
so i can't wait to i mean that's a title
of an episode alone for once
elon musk is starting his own social
media
love that story jordan peterson updates
our georgia peace it does support
conversion therapy we have proof
why is this still in the dock this is
from like two months ago
it's been in there very well is it good
or not i mean it's just we've moved so
far past it where would we be without
conversion therapy it just keeps
there'll just be gays running around
everywhere
but yeah uh to everybody who said no he
didn't and we were misinterpreting what
he said
you're wrong yeah so who is gay
can we do a poll on what people think of
the stash
oh sure yeah that's a good idea i'm
curious i like it or not
what are you seeing support or i've seen
a few comments uh not i
don't know that's why i think we're
sorry guys we're talking into the
michael show that's why you guys got to
go right we're finally ending the poll
it
had
uh over 50 000 votes uh it held pretty
much steady at 80 no 20 yet so
you know about
wait i don't see the poll you put it up
i no i'm just talking about the old poll
i left it up that whole time about the
slide what was the final result final
result 52 000 votes
uh just shy 80 said no
20
said yes
so 20 man which looking at the chat
that wouldn't that tells the difference
yeah i'm looking at twitter by the way
did you show the one i wanted to show
the ones that i got ratioed on
because like that was making me lose my
mind on twitter the guy who said you
don't know anything well we talked about
it wait i said uh
you don't know anything about defending
your wife yeah and it had like 120 000
likes i was just so confused yeah and
then i guess take the pile on people if
anybody who watches the show knows that
true you stand up for you all the time
i was just surprised that i mean shout
out to that frankly you can stand up for
herself i mean
exactly but i also stand up for you
looking dunk with the best of them but i
guess i need to stab keemstar or
something
stand up for i don't know what they want
from me just a joke of course i would
never do that to keemstar ever i hate
keemstar i have no violent uh body of my
bone for anybody you know murderer
you know i was the one saying we should
move on from unlike keemstar who's
killed dogs anyway
go ahead dan
i know i was the one that said we should
move on but can we just take a moment
to just acknowledge the absolutely
batshit insane oh yeah i knew where
i wanted this one too yeah because these
these are judd go the other direction
for a second yeah exactly was this in
the dark i missed yeah yeah it's at the
bottom of the oscars section oh [ __ ]
yeah i wanted to talk about people on
the opposite left let's make the 20 of
our audience that uh said it was
justified happy for a moment because
some of these takes are wow judd apatow
he said go up he could have killed him
well
okay now now like come on bro that's
pure out of control raging violence
they've heard a million jokes about them
in the last few decades they're not
freshmen of the world of hollywood
comedy he lost his mind all good
he could have killed him
it's a lot i don't know i don't know
about that
yeah i don't know about that it's like
bro why'd you have to say that and it's
it's similar to what will did it's like
well everything you did was great
except punching right and then but
that's kind of a big part of it right
that's why judd erased this tweet in
shame yeah right we should say uh yeah
that one disappeared pretty quickly
steve schmidt is this a guy that i would
know uh you probably see he's like a
talking head on cable news all the time
[ __ ]
like he's a he's a never trump
republican he was a huge republican for
a long time but he hates trump and he
makes everything about trump and somehow
he managed here oh he did that yeah
interesting the oscars have demonstrated
the power of group psychology the room
is hermetically sealed bubble where all
moors can be eradicated in a second you
know the constant people about to get
gassed in this [ __ ] next
do you want to understand how trump
happened watch the oscars in the crowd
reaction
the pull to belong is very powerful dude
shut the [ __ ] up
it's like i want to have a real
conversation and like judd being like he
could have killed him yeah this is how
trump happened y'all are just dumb
hyperbolic it's just you're not actually
engaging you're just like making it
about yourself wait let me read this
follow-up tweet
a poll to conform to what is happening
around you is a powerful tide
applause for assault in a tuxedo in
california the same as applause for
assault while wearing a red hat in
alabama
that's true
that i agree with it's a little dramatic
well it's just like dude you don't have
to take it there
the will smith doctrine
oh he's baking about ukraine yeah
there's a lot of these actually
reward in return for aggression has no
place in the resolution of the ukraine
war what the [ __ ]
the us was like damn i didn't i didn't
realize that my
that got really [ __ ] up
i just i just bombed a bunch of
poor civilians in ukraine
so did anyone talk uh did anyone walk
out after that happened or are we
getting an independent psychological
case study and how trump got normalized
shut the [ __ ] up you guys
oh i saw this one got re deleted really
fast real fast
hang on i got a drink my throat's
agitated
let me read that
if only will smith got as upset when
white men take away his right to vote
whoops that's a hot take
she immediately deleted that
real quick
it's just that's like a uh
a common fallacy you see when anything
happens it's like oh you're mad about
this then why are you mad about this
other thing happening right
let's just talk about one thing okay
to clarify in the earlier tweet i had to
delete obviously i'm not saying it was
the same as 911. i looked so hard for
the original delete he must deleted it
so fast because i could not find a
screenshot of it anywhere it's already
good
but will smith clapping chris rock
slapping chris rock had a similar
live tv shock value that will echo
throughout our culture 911 was worse
but
but
mohammed added did not win an oscar
right after
oh so so i mean in some ways
yeah that's pretty wild man you guys are
crazy
actually more crazier takes like this
then
opposite
if will smith was a white guy he would
have been led out of the oscars in
handcuffs
then police would have thrown him in
jail there would be a thousand media
headpieces about him being racist
he would be canceled for life instead he
won best actor that's privilege and
there's the conservative right version
of that the white uh yeah
the the uh
this one starts out it's the white
victim you already take you already know
this one's going to be your head yo
let's do this
august
if you're curious why germans allowed
hitler to happen
more americans allowed george w bush to
lead us into iraq
why russians are allowing putin to
murder ukraine look at how the oscar
crowd
reacted
crowd and his supporters handled will
smith tonight now
maybe a little sense of pursuit i think
the oscar crowd there was a lot of shock
and confusion
i do think it was pretty corny that they
gave him a standing o after that it's
just weird yeah
but
okay
engineered by putin to take the
spotlight off ukraine what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's pretty insane lady
i guess that's it there were a lot i did
see a really funny tweet by tim dillon
he was like anyway last night russia
nuked ukraine and uh nobody noticed
all right i'm putting up the stashpool
ethan's stash
let me know what you guys think i
actually like it you know what should we
say is ethan's mustache a vibe yes or no
jesus christ dude
[Music]
you come to me
and you vote on if you like my stash
hey i'll tell you what this mustache
don't know nothing about nobody
what do everyone talking about is slap i
don't know nothing about a slap
all right let's see
some vote yes some vote no
smash cam what do i know oh
okay
71 yes
nice
and there it is
go chris rock apologize a statement he
just put out a statement it's all
happening live on h3 podcast today he
actually just released the statement i'm
breaking exclusive to zach zach is in
touch with him now live
go ahead this is a h3 podcast exclusive
av go ahead what were you gonna say
i'm looking for now just checked on
instagram i'm not seeing on instagram or
twitter
[Music]
this was according to
the chat
that he made a statement
[Music]
i saw a a uh super chat
they're saying i look like nacho libre
thank you
someone said chris rock put out a
statement apologizing
i think they were i think i think
they're confusing will smith with chris
rock oh man someone's saying it's fake
did we just get lily's on good oh okay i
just got zonked put out a video of
zach and blackface
okay like you just got songs oh my god
no
uh nothing on his twitter which is where
i imagine he would have issued some sort
of statement on it so uh yeah i think we
got zonked wait wouldn't
willy want willy wonka to apply for will
smith like it would just be willy wonka
with the w
oh [ __ ]
yeah i don't know what you do if it's a
w willy smelly
willy wonked well yeah so it would it
would kind of work right
well chris rock would be a chrissy chris
ricky chris cocked chris conked cursed
is he ricky chrissy ricky
chilly chunked chili all right well
that's enough for today what do you guys
think about all that
it's a false alarm on chris rock not an
exclusive scoop here today
but anyway we have so much to talk about
on wednesday so we had fun
i can't wait to talk about this david
dober crypto uh scam what a dude that's
so awesome
it's so awesome wait until you see the
video
oh there's a video yes dude i again wait
yeah crypto [ __ ] save it because yeah
trying to avoid watching it until the
wednesday yeah
come watch on wednesday because i'm
pretty jacked on that
all right guys well thanks for watching
have a good week we'll be back on
wednesday of course
[Music]
wait hold on i got a lot of comments
here somebody just
hassan was just streaming some sort of
statement from chris but i think it may
have been faked
fake news this on as always
spreading that fake news
[Laughter]
yeah i just heard a song there's a clip
of a sun flowing around he said actually
um
insta stories they're saying apology on
insta stories
okay we got an update exclusive might be
happening
he has no insta story
a pup god damn it julian you don't you
donated 10 bucks to lie to me
thank you for the ten dollars i
wait i didn't feel like she wouldn't lie
maybe you're you're gonna be a racer i'm
on chris rock's profile
like i don't know why she would lie
about that
chris
rock apology
it must have let's see
a chris rock apology on twitter
man that minute we end the show it's
gonna come out uh
i mean
yeah again will smith's statement was
put on his story
wait he posted on his instagram stories
yeah like
okay i i assume everyone's gonna see it
regardless oh yeah i mean it's all over
the place
well there you have it folks
uh yeah and so if people are confused
maybe they just came in but yeah we saw
the apology we talked about it already
so thank you thank you we got it
we got it all right come back wednesday
it's gonna be fun guys have a great week
we'll see you then
god bless stay safe
and all the yada yada and all that stuff
okay
be good thank you guys
[Music]
you